voilà je vous propose de de commencer
notre audition et on va laisser les les
documents sur le bilan prévisionnel
édition 2023 Finant d'être distribué à
l'ensemble de nos collègues donc bonjour
à toutes et à tous et nous avons le
plaisir aujourd'hui d'accueillir
Monsieur Xavier pichazik qui est le
président du directoire de réseau de
transport d'électricité plus connu sous
le nom de RTE afin d'échanger avec lui
sur l'actualité du secteur de l'énergie
et notamment le devenir de notre mix
électrique le 25 octobre dernier le
président de la République a annoncé
l'examen d'une loi pour déterminer notre
mix énergétique en décembre ainsi qu'une
consultation sur la future programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie PPE en
octobre cette annonce qui reste pour
l'heure à concrétiser est positive pour
les droits du Parlement et la transition
énergétique je rappelle que c'est le
Sénat et singulièrement notre commission
qui dans la loi énergie climat de 2019 a
posé le principe d'une loi de
programmation sur l'énergie prévalent
sur tous les document réglementaire dont
la PPE c'était un amendement de Daniel
gréier un amendement de notre collègue
Daniel gremmiller ce faisant il s'est
agit de remplacer la représentation
nationale au cœur de la transition
énergétique en faisant prévaloir la
politique sur la le politique sur la
technique pour relever les défis
colossaux qui sont devant nous c'est
dans ce contexte que nous avons souhaité
entendre RTE le gestionnaire du réseau
de transport d'électricité dont les
missions sont je le rappelle d'assurer
l'équilibre entre la production et la
consommation
d'électricité d'opérer la transition
énergétique en adaptant les réseaux et
d'éclairer la décision des pouvoirs
publics sur les questions énergétiques
parmi les travaux de prospective
désormais bien connu de RTE figure son
étude futur énergétique à l'horizon
2050 qui a été publié en octobre
2021 puis actualisé en juin 2022 et en
septembre
2023 je souhaiterais monsieur le
Président donc recueillir votre point de
vue sur sur CIN aspects de votre étude
le premier aspect concerne le mix
électrique selon cette étude six mix
sont proposés à l'horizon 2050 allant de
100 % d'énergie renouvelable à 50 %
d'énergie nucléaire les coûts
d'investissement du scénario le plus
renouvelable seraient supérieur de 200
milliards d'euros à ceux du plus
nucléarisé
cela signifie-t-il que l'énergie
nucléaire est indispensable pour
contenir le coût de production de
l'électricité le second aspect que je
veux évoquer avec vous a trait à la
relance de l'énergie nucléaire pour
conserver un mix majoritairement
nucléarisé à l'horizon
2050 14 PR2 et 4 GW de SMR serait requis
pour votre étude y a-t-il ence a décidé
de la construction des 8 PR2
supplémentaires en plus des 6 annoncé
par le président de la République dans
son discours de bellefort du 10 janvier
2022 compte tenu des délais de
développement
incompressible le troème aspect porte
sur l'évolution de la consommation
d'électricité selon votre étude la
consommation d'électricité pourrait
atteindre 640 wh dès
2035 pour réaliser les objectifs de
décarbonation et
d'industrialisation c'était le niveau
attendu pour 2050 dans l'ancien scénario
de référence de RTE dans ce contexte
faut-il construire davantage de
réacteurs que les 14 epr2 et 4 GW de SMR
je rappelle que RTE avait indiqué à
titre ustratif qu'un effort d'adaptation
du mix de production porté par la seule
filière nucléaire associé à une
perspective de
réindustrialisation profonde représenté
9 PR2 est-ce toujours le cas un autre
aspect vise la maîtrise de la
consommation d'électricité pour faire
face à la hausse de la consommation
quatre leviers sont identifiés dans
votre étude l'efficacité énergétique
jusqu'à
100wh la sobriété jusqu'à 60 TWh la
production d'électricité renouvelable
jusqu'à 320 tawh et la production
d'énergie nucléaire jusqu'à 400 TWh le
levier de l'efficacité énergétique ne
nécessite pas d'accélérer sur les
rénovations énergétiques je rappelle que
le nombre de rénovations global
performante ne dépasse pas
100000 contre des objectifs qui devrai
être de
370000 jusqu'en 2030 et de 700000 à
partir de 2030 jusqu'en 2050 selon
l'actuelle stratégie nationale
baccarbone s'agissant du levier de la
sobriété énergétique quels sont les
gestes nécessaires à son atteinte et qui
doit les supporter les administrations
les professionnels les parties
particulier enfin les rythmes de
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
comme nucléaire sont-ils bien réalistes
au regard des capacités industrielles
des filières le dernier aspect concerne
la souveraineté énergétique de la France
avec une consommation énergétique
composée de 60 % d'énergie fossile la
facture énergétique de la France s'élève
entre 25 et 100 milliards d'euros
l'étude de RTE estime que
l'électrification peut permettre de
réduire cette facture énergétique de 5 à
10 milliards d'euros ne doit-on pas
faire plus et par quel levier la
diminution de la consommation d'énergie
fossile mais aussi la production en
France de biogaz et de biocarburant ne
peuvent-ils pas y contribuer enfin si
vous me permettez monsieur le Président
je voudrais vous poser une question plus
directement liée à mon territoire les
Alpes Maritimes mais aussi au départ
appartement du Var puisque le 11 octobre
dernier 260000 foyers ont été privés
d'électricité
entre 20h et
21h45 suite à un incendie sur la ligne à
haute tension de 400000 volts qui relie
Tavel près d'Avignon à carrosse dans les
Alpes Maritimes contrairement au
blackout que nous avions connu en 2008
le filet de sécurité électrique a permis
d'éviter le pire pour autant cette panne
ne manque pas de nous interroger sur les
garanties de sécurité en
approvisionnement électrique qui nous
avait été faite par RTE lors de
l'installation de ce dispositif à
l'approche de l'hiver les habitants des
Alpes Maritimes et du Var attendent des
clarifications à ce sujet que
pouvez-vous que pouvez-vous nous dire
que pouvez-vous leur dire monsieur le
Président de RTE voilà je souhaite que
vous puissiez dans votre intervention
liminaire répondre à toutes ou partie
des questions que je vous ai posé et
ensuite bien sûr on ouvrira les
questions à l'ensemble des commissaires
en passant d'abord par nos rapporteurs
que sont Daniel grrimier à la fois
Patrick Chauvet et Fabien Guay ainsi que
Pierre cuupers et ensuite on ouvrira
plus largement les débats la parole est
à vous monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et les sénateurs merci de
nous accueillir je suis accompagné de
Thomas verin qui est membre du
directoire de RTE notamment en charge
des sujets euh de prospective alors si
vous me permettez on va faire un propos
liminaire à deux voix pour que ce soit
plus vivant euh vous présenter euh
l'essentiel de ce qu'on a dit dans ce
dans ce bilan prévisionnel qui est sous
vos yeux dont nous vous avons remis un
exemplaire et puis j'en profiterai au
fil de mon propos madame la présidente
si vous en êtes d'accord pour répondre à
vos questions euh qui sont précises et
je vous en remercie
euh l'étude que vous avez sous les yeux
est une est une mise à jour est une
grosse étude ça a demandé beaucoup de
travail et c'est une une mise à jour de
la première période de futur énergétique
2050 madame la Présidente vous avez
eu l'amabilité de de faire référence à
ce gros travail que nous avions publié
en fin 2021 mais euh mais pour lequel
les travaux avaient commencé dès
2019 et nous
avons ce travail d'ici 2050 vaut
toujours à l'échéance 2050 il a décrit
vous l'avez dit six chemins possibles
d'électrification euh de la France qui
dépend déjà infin de de choix politique
hein mais depuis le moment où nous avons
euh produit futur énergétique 2050 il
s'est produit un certain nombre de
choses nouvelles euh qui justifiait que
que nous mettions à jour la première
période de cette séquence donc en fait
entre aujourd'hui et 2050 nous avons
découpé le temps en deux entre
aujourd'hui et 2035 et entre 2035 et
2050 et donc nous avons actualisé la
première période du chemin vers la
neutralité carbone donc à cette échéance
2035 alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
depuis euh
2020-2021 il s'est passé euh un certain
nombre de choses qui sont nouvelles ou
qui se sont confirmées et qui
justifiaient cette mise à jour euh la
première c'est que la France s'est
engagée dans le feed for 55 alors bien
évidemment en
2020-2021 euh le sujet été en discussion
euh au sein des institutions
communautaires euh et ce feed for505 il
nous oblige puisque vous savez que
l'Union a décidé finalement de durcir
ses objectifs de baisse de ses émissions
carbon d'ici 2030 hein donc c'est un
jalon 2030 c'est ce n'est que dans 7 ans
et bientôt dans 6 ans pour faire baisser
de 55 % nos émissions de CO2 par rapport
à à 1990 est-ce que je voudrais que tout
le monde entendre c'est que ce nouvel
objectif que s'est doté l'Union au début
de l'année 2022 il nous oblige et il est
plus dur que le précédent donc il nous
oblige à une forme d'accélération et
c'est la première raison pour laquelle
il fallait qu'on a actualise cette
première période de futur énergétique
euh il y a eu d'autres éléments qui qui
justifia cette cette mise à jour la
première c'est que le pays c'est s'est
engagé dans une forme de
réindustrialisation pour plusieurs
raisons pour des raisons économiques que
tout le monde entend pour des raisons
qui sont postérieures au covid au moment
où la France s'est retrouvée
constaté des trous dans son tissu
industriel pour la production d'un
certain nombre de biens euh euh et voilà
ce mouvement est devenu donc une
politique publique qui est en train de
fonctionner puisque vous avez entendu
les uns et les autres euh un certain
nombre de grands prospects de grands
industriels du monde promettre des
investissements sur sur le sol français
donc on est dans une démarche de euh
souveraineté industrielle et puis est
venu euh dans le débat la question de la
souveraineté en terme d'énergie qui est
la conséquence de la guerre en Ukraine
avec les fortes tensions qu'il a eu sur
les approvisionnements de pétrole et de
gaz et qui ont mis au centre du jeu la
question de de sortir plus vite de notre
dépendance du pétrole et surtout du gaz
donc il y a l'ensemble de ces phénomènes
qui justifia qu'on fasse cette mise à
jour parce que il comporte tous une
forme d'accélér du mouvement vers la
neutralité carbone pour plusieurs
raisons
différentes voilà la nature de ce que
vous avez sous sous vos yeux alors cette
mise à jour de cette première période de
futur énergétique 2050 elle décrit
toujours cette bascule cette grande
bascule des énergies fossiles vers des
énergies qui sont décarbonées
l'électricité ne sera demain pas la
seule énergie décarboné vous l'avez
rappelé il y a aussi ce qui viendra du
monde des bioénergies et notamment le le
biogaz on y on y reviendra mais ce dont
on est sûr aujourd'hui c'est que si on
veut atteindre notre jalon de 2030 du
fit for 55 si on va être sur la bonne
trajectoire en 2035 et si on va être à
l'heure en 2050 il faut que la France
s'électrifie et qu'elle
s'électrifie vite sachant que
l'électricité produite doit être
produite par des moyens des carboné en
France nous avons déjà une électricité
fortement décarbonée dans ses émissions
puis que elle est à plus de 9 %
décarbonés grâce au nucléaire d'une part
et grâce au développement des énergies
renouvelables d'autre
part je met l'hydraulique dans les dans
dans les énergies renouvelable
euh je vais vous l'avez dit dans je est
là d'abord la France est un pays qui
aujourd'hui consomme plus de 60 % toutes
énergies confondu d'énergie fossile donc
du pétrole et du gaz fossile et le
premier défi c'est bien de se demander
comment le pays d'ici 2050 arrête de
dépendre à 63 % de sa consommation
d'énergie finale du pétrole et du gaz
fossile sachant que ce pétrole et ce gaz
fossile n'est pas pas produit sur le sol
français nous en dépendant d'un certain
nombre de pays que je ne vais pas
décrire ici mais avec qui les relations
politiques ne sont pas toujours au beau
fix et on retombe là sur le sujet de la
souveraineté c'est aussi une question
financière vous l'avez dit vous l'avez
dit madame la Présidente
puisque la facture énergétique
essentiellement pétrolière et gazière de
la France en 2022 était de 120 milliards
d'euros
et en moyenne sur sur les 10 dernières
années était de 50 milliards d'euros et
ces milliards d'euros que je cite là ce
sont pas des investissements productifs
sur le sol français c'est une facture
d'énergie qu'on paye à d'autres voilà je
cite ces chiffres parce que on on va
parler 2 milliards d'euros pour le
développement du système électrique ils
peuvent vous paraître importants mais
c'est important qu'on cite ces chiffre
de la facture pétrolière et gazière
annuelle parce que c'est un bon ordre de
grandeur pour remettre à sa place ce que
peut coûter le système électrique de
main
et et il peut nous conduire à une
neutralité carbone qui soit tout à fait
tout à fait accessible pour les
industriels et pour les ménages français
donc on est dans cette histoire du Grand
switch alors nous nous travaillons
lorsque nous faisons des documents
prospectif nous travaillons toujours
avec plusieurs scénarios et c'est
aujourd'hui ce que nous avons refait et
ce qui c'est sous vos yeux pour décrire
des
chemins des chemins énergétique
possible je reviendrai
aussi Thomas verin le fera sur le fait
que tout ça est toujours fait à la suite
d'une très grande concertation avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes donc au
cours desquelles nous testons nous
analysons et nous débattons de
l'ensemble de nos hypothèses donc nous
n'inventons en rien tout ça est très
concerté et dans le document que vous
avez sous les yeux
euh nous avons décrit euh trois euh
trois futurs énergétiques possibles à
l'échéance
2035 nous décrivons des chemins
possibles nous n'avons jamais fait de
prédiction RTE ne fait pas de prédiction
RTE
euh analyse les paramètres et les
politiques publiques du moment intègre
les paramètres macro-économiques et
dessine des chemins possibles après il
revient au politique à l'exécutif à la
représentation nationale de comparer ses
chemins et de faire des
choix euh alors les trois chemins
possibles à échéance 2035 mais qui
sont la première étape ver vers 2050
vous l'avez dit
euh h il y en a un qui s'appelle a c'est
très simple que nous avons appelé le
scénario de référence et que le scénario
qu'on pourrait donc appeler le scénario
souhaitable pour être au rendez-vous de
nos ambitions c'est le scénario qui nous
permet de combiner l'accélération de la
décarbonation issue du fit for 55 et qui
nous permet en même temps donc
d'accélérer notre
réindustrialisation et donc d'accélérer
notre souveraineté en matière d'énergie
c'est le scénario a alors chez nous il
est décliné en plusieurs variantes il y
a a bas mais il y a un a
référence et c'est et c'est celui-là
madame qui nous conduit
à dessiner une trajectoire de
consommation si la France veut atteindre
ses objectifs centrit à
615 taraw de consommation en 2035 640
c'est la trajectoire haute
euh euh à 615 tawh de consommation du
pays en
c'est pour
revenir à la référence de futur
énergétique 2050 c'est dans notre
travail de futur énergétique 2050 ça
correspond aux trajectoires de
consommation qui sont décrites que nous
avions déjà décrites en
2021 qui s'appelle réindustrialisation
profonde puisque c'est la démarche dans
laquelle nous sommes combiné à celle
d'une électrification qui est accélérée
parce que ça c'est les c'est les
conséquences du fit for 55 donc on est
dans le monde de réindustrialisation
profonde et d'une électrification
accéléré et oui lorsqu'on cumule les
consommations dans cette perspective là
on arrive à un ordre de grandeur de 615
tawh de consommation France en
2035 encore faut-il que que la France et
on y reviendra dans le débat je suppose
réussisse cette bascule vers
l'électrification aujourd'hui la France
consomme un peu moins de 450 TWh par an
donc vous voyez que la marche la marche
est élevée et ce que je vous dire c'est
que c'est contretendantiel c'est
conttendantiel parce que depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'années la consommation
de l'électricité de la France stagne ou
baisse
elle stagnait structurellement et elle a
baissé pour un nombre de paramètres qui
sont exogènes aussi à nos politiques
publiques notamment la crise du covid
mais si les paramètres macro-économiques
mondiaux restent ceux qu'ils sont
effectivement si la reprise est plus
lente ça
décalera cette cette
contretendance donc voilà pour votre
première évocation on est toujours dans
le monde de futur énergétique 2050 dans
la variante réindustrialisation profonde
et dans sa variante électrification
accélérée je vous renvoie pour ça au
document complet futur énergétique 2050
qui est en ligne et donc ce jalon à 2035
il nous conduit à faire une estimation
d'une consommation souitable de 615
TWh on a testé deux autres scénarios
parce que outre le fait que nous nous
nous souhaitons éclairer la le débat
public le débat parlementaire et les
décisions publiques notre c'est aussi
d'assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et on doit se
prémunir de l'ensemble des scénarios
possibles donc nous avons la tradition
de faire toujours un certain nombre de
scénarios qui sont alternatifs ou qui
peuvent être des scénarios
dégradés nous avons testé donc un
scénario B et un scénario C alors le
scénario B c'est un scénario dans lequel
la France est en retard la France est en
retard dans son électrification euh
c'est aussi un monde dans lequel la
France pourra être en retard dans la
manière dont mon un stade des des
énergies renouvelables enfin c'est
essentiellement un monde dans lequel la
France pe à basculer des usages
pétroliers du gaz fossile vers
l'électricité et donc ça ça veut dire
que bah de fait en 2035 la France
consomme un peu moins et donc on atteint
moins bien nos objectifs de
réindustrialisation et de
souveraineté on en a testé un avec 3 ans
de retard et un avec 5 ans de retard
pour être précis pour les chiffres
détaillés vous avez vous vous avez des
tableaux de synthèse sous les yeux et
puis nous avons testé un autre scénario
que nous avons appelé mondialisation
contrariée et dans l'état d'esprit et de
se demander que se passe-t-il si le
contexte macroéconomique mondial reste
ce qu'il est
c'est-à-dire une inflation haute des
taux d'intérêt haut des matières
premières qui restent chèes une
consommation structurellement plus plus
cher un
renchérissement des coûts équipement
nécessaire à la
transition une augmentation des coûts de
financement de la production du au taux
d'intérêt haut voilà le contexte
macroéconomique dont nous sortons nous
avons testé le monde dans lequel il se
prolonge parce que bien
évidemment la réindustrialisation
française ne peut pas ne s'envisage pas
de la même manière si des taux d'intérêt
redeviennent
bas parce que bah parce que les capacité
d'emprunt des entreprises ne sont pas
les mêmes si la consommation des
Français reste plutôt basse bah donc
effectivement ça tire l'économie
française à la baisse et donc on a testé
ce monde là euh finalement la question à
laquelle on tente de répondre c'est
comment faire cette transition
énergétique et cette neutralité carbone
et comment atteindre nos bons jalons
2035 dans un monde adverse adverse
économiquement et adverse aussi sur le
commerce mondial sur les
sujets des matières premières voilà
euh pour le contexte donc ce que je
voulais vous dire Madame la la présence
c'est qu'il n'y a pas euh il n'y a pas
contradiction entre futur énergétique
2050 et ce que nous avons publié en tant
que mise à jour simplement la mise à
jour de cette première période elle se
situe sur la borne haute des
trajectoires de consommation de futur
énergétique 2050
que nous avons euh publié en
2021 alors si vous permettez je vais
m'intéresser au scénario a le scénario
dans lequel la France atteint
ses ses objectifs et dans lequel la
France atteint ses ambitions donc ses
engagements européens du FED for55 sa
réindustrialisation et l'accélération de
son indépendance énergétique et donc ça
c'est le scénario a vous avez remarqué
qu'effectivement cela
projette une consommation France de 615
taw donc ça fait ça fait 30 % grosso
modo de plus qu'aujourd'hui je vous ai
dit que c'était contre tendanciel et
donc la question qu'on se pose dans dans
ces cas-là c'est bah en fait sur quel
paramètres il faut jouer pour pouvoir
couvrir cette consommation de 615 TWh en
2035 et vous l'avez dit Madame pour que
l'ensemble du système boucle finalement
nous avons av on dit qu'il fallait jouer
sur quatre Levi en même temps le levier
de la sobriété le levier de l'efficacité
le levier du nucléaire et le levier des
énergies
renouvelables alors je vais commencer
par
l'efficacité il faut qu'on continue à
être efficace lorsqu'on consomme de
l'électricité alors l'efficacité c'est
l'ensemble des dispositif technique qui
nous permet de consommer moins
d'électricité pour un même usage un
exemple que tout le monde connaît
lorsque vous changez votre frigo et que
vous allez vous acheter un nouveau frigo
votre ancien frigo avait 15 ans ou 20
ans le nouveau votre nouveau frigo
consomme moins par nature parce que les
constructeurs font des efforts en
matière de consommation d'énergie et
c'est vrai pour
tout euh donc ça c'est une sorte
d'efficacité technique qu'il faut bien
évidemment poursuivre et on met dans ce
mot dans ce concept
d'efficacité aussi la rénovation
thermique qui est un dispositif
technique qui Perm
de consommer structurellement moins
d'électricité et donc nous avons
dimensionné cette efficacité à 100 TW
vous avez raison d'ici 2035 et ça
suppose un certain nombre d'effort sur
la rénovation thermique Thomas vous en
dira un mot deuxème levier c'est la
sobriété alors la sobriété c'est pas
l'efficacité la sobriété chez nous c'est
les changements de comportement donc nos
changements d'usage et de
consommation qui font qu'on consommerait
structurellement moins d'énergie alors
je veux vous le dire ici très
officiellement la première sobriété à
faire c'est celle sur les énergies
fossile puisque le le début de mon
propos vous relatez la facture fossile
et le premier enjeu c'est de consommer
moins de fossil donc la première
sobriété à mettre en œuvre c'est la
sobriété sur les énergies
fossiles mais nous avons aussi besoin
pour atteindre ces objectifs qui sont
très rapprochés en 2030 et en
2035 de désormais d'une sobriété en
matière d'électricité et là nous avons
descis de monde un monde de la sobriété
des gestes simples sur lesquels on
reviendra qu'on a dimensionné à 25 TWh
c'est la sobriété que les Français ont
fait l'hiver dernier c'est pour un
ménage sa température de
chauffage le réglage de sa température
de ballon d'eau chaude et son éclairage
voilà c'est ça la sobriété des gestes
simples et puis euh on a testé un monde
avec une sobriété renforcée qui elle oui
suppose des changements de comportements
qui sont plus structurels euh notamment
sur les questions de mobilité de
consommation de ce point de vue les
Français nous disent qu'ils ne sont pas
tous prêts à rentrer dans ce Mondel euh
je vous renvoie mesdames et messieurs à
une deux grosses enquêtes que nous avons
fait avec hipsos que nous avons publié
qui sont en ligne sur notre site
Internet en juin dernier auprès du plus
gros panel français représentatif de
12000 français pour leur poser la
question de leur appétence à
s'électrifier et à être sobre j'ai pas
le temps aujourd'hui de vous la raconter
mais si vous êtes intéressé je je vous
renvoie donc à ces documents et dans le
scénario central on a retenu une
sobriété en matière d'électricité de 25
TWh c'est-à-dire la sobriété des gestes
simples on n'est pas dans une
sobriété dans on n pas dans un monde
pénurique on est dans un monde plutôt
Paron du raccourci de chasse au gaspi ça
c'est le deuxème levier mais celui-là il
faut qu'on l'active aussi pour atteindre
l'objectif du fit for55 d'une part et
celui
celui de 2035 qui est le
chemin vers 2050 ça c'est les doiers sur
la consommation
et on peut pas les éliminer il faut
qu'on les traite et puis il y en a deux
autres sur la production et donc je vais
commencer par le socle nucléaire nous
avons dit 400 tawh souhaitaable et nous
avons tablé sur 360 terw de production
par an c'est une hypothèse
volontairement prudente et cette
hypothèse de production nucléaire d'ici
2035 elle intègre Flamanville 3 donc le
projet de PR qui est en cours
de mise en service je suppose que nous
aurons des questions là-dessus comme là
je suis dans le monde de 2035 il y a pas
de PR 2 hein on est avant le déploiement
du programme du nouveau
nucléaire et puis ce soocle nucléaire
qu'on connaît déjà puisque en fait les
centrales nucléaires qui vont produire
d'ici 2035 elles sont déjà construites
elle fonctionne il y en aura pas de
nouvell d'ici 2035 et donc le complément
c'est énergies renouvelables et donc
effectivement ça nous projette dans un
monde où il faudrait que la
France donc produis un minimum de 270
TWh d'énergie renouvelable par an et
jusqu'à 320 TWh alors pardon je vous
assomme de chiffres mais c'est important
qu'on s'arrête là-dessus aujourd'hui la
France produit 120 TWh d'énergie
renouvelable 50 % c'est
l'hydraulique
et 60 TWh c'est ce qui est produit par
les éoliennes qu'ell soit offshore ou
sur terre et sur le photovoltaïque donc
120wh 60 pour l'hydro le
reste 60 pour l'hydro 60 pour le
photovoltaïque et l'éolien en ordre de
grandeur il faut qu'on atteigne au moins
en volume anuel le potentiel
d'hydroélectricité français on peut le
faire croîre un peu mais ce sera pas
déterminant d'ici
donc l'enjeu il se joue sur le
photovoltaïque et sur
l'éolien il est là et donc en ordre de
grandeur ça veut dire
que il faudrait que la France d'ici 2035
multiplie par 4 le volume de production
annuelle d'électricité issu de ces modes
de production en
volume si vous voulez on reviendra après
sur les hectares et les nombres de vous
allez voir qu'on est dans des
proportions qui sont largement
inférieure à à celle de nos voisins
européens
euh c'est ce que je vous dis là n'est
pas un parti prix je vous ai parlé du
socle nucléaire le socle nucléaire il
est on a fait des hypothèses dessus
elles ont été concertées on a pris on a
dit que 400 TW étaient souhaitabl et que
nous on on on préférait tabler
prudemment sur un sur un 360 mais quand
vous êtes dans un monde qui consomme
plus de 600 TWh par an bah en fait il
faut bien trouver la différence et
lorsque vous et et lorsque votre
capacité en matière d'hydroélectricité
est plus ou moins plafonnée même si on
pourra gagner quelques pourcents et bien
donc il faut trouver des moyens de de
production complémentaire qu'on a le
temps de construire d'ici 2035 et quels
sont les moyens de production
complémentaires qu'on a le temps de
construire d'ici 2035 c'est
essentiellement du photovoltaïque et de
l'éolien qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en
matière de
proportion dans le mix électrique je je
vais commencer par le sol
on a dit qu'il faudrait que la France
alors je vais parler de rythme par an ça
me ça permet de mesurer l'effort qu'il
faut
faire on a dit qu'en matière de
photovoltaïque il faudrait que la France
se mette sur le rythme de 4 GWh par an
minimum et que le souhaitable ce serait
7 GW par an c'est une c'est une
fourchette c'est un
encadrement est-ce que ça fait une
grosse différence par rapport à
aujourd'hui pas vraiment puis puisque
historiquement le photovoltaïque était
plutôt à 2 Gow par an mais je crois que
l'année 2023 devrait finir sur un 3 Gow
donc on est déjà à 3 et donc il faudrait
qu'on passe minimum à 4 donc on est dans
ces ordres de grandeur
là je vais passer à l'éolien l'éolien on
a repris à notre compte l'hypothèse du
gouvernement qui a été largement débattu
devant devant votre assemblée de 18 GW
d'offshore en 2035 aujourd'hui vous
savez qu'il y a des appel d'offre qui
sont décidés pour à peu près 10 et ces
projets sont en travaux c'est tous les
appels d'offre qui ont émaillé ces
dernières années ce sont des projets que
nous raccordons saint-nazer est en
service bientôt saint-briux courseul
fécan plus tard d'unkererque et
cetera on a repris à notre compte
l'hypothèse de 18 en
2035 en
gigw et puis la concertation avec les
parties prenantes nous a conduit à
tester trois scénarios de développement
d'éolien
terrestre un scénario dit de rythme lent
à 0,7 GW par
an un rythme médian et un rythme
[Musique]
haut le rythme l c'est 07 par an c'est
deux fois moins de développement
d'éolien terrestrre qu'aujourd'hui
puisqueaujourd'hui notre notre rythme
c'est de
1,5 1,5 GW par an donc on a testé le
monde de euh on ralentit le
développement de l'éolien
terrestre il y a le scénario médian qui
consiste à continuer le rythme de
développement de l'éolien terrestre
d'aujourd'hui donc 1,5 GW par an et
c'est ce que nous avons retenu dans
notre hypothèse
centrale et puis il y a le scénario où
il où on accélérerait l'éolien euh
terrestre et on le passerait à 2 GW par
an mais aujourd'hui retenez que ce que
la France fait de manière effective
c'est
1,5 donc les chiffres peuvent être
effrayant lorsqu'on les donne brut en
volume de production admelle mais vous
voyez que dès qu'on parle de rythme dès
lors qu'on arrive à faire 18 GW
d'éolien maritime on est dans un monde
qui qui ne relève pas de bouleversement
des rythmes d'aujourd'hui certes c'est
une accélération certes c'est un effort
mais on est on est dans des ordres de
grandeur
comparables
avec ceux
d'aujourd'hui je sais que lesolien
terrestre fait
discussion je vaux juste vous donner un
ordre de
grandeur la France pourrait décider de
passer sur un rythme de développement de
de l'éolien terrestre de
0,7 soit deux fois moins rapide
qu'aujourd'hui donc on diviserait le
rythme par deux c'est toujours possible
mais à ce momentl il nous manquerait de
la production
électricité et donc ça voudrait dire que
bah il faudrait qu'on fasse baisser la
consommation et donc il faudrait qu'on
se retrouve dans un monde sobre et cet
éolien terrestre qui nous manquerait
c'est à peu près 20 20 tawh de sobriété
à trouver donc en ordre de grandeur si
je divise par deux le rythme de
développement de l'éolien terrestre le
défi de la France ce sera de ne plus
être dans une sobriété des gestes
simples mais dans une sobriété
beaucoup plus structurel qui elle
aussi posera des questions si ce n'est
d'acceptabilité au moins d'adhésion
d'une d'une grande partie de la
population
française je vous ai dit que dans notre
dans notre soocle nucléaire il y avait
pas de PR parce que il est officiel que
les nouveaux PR2 ne rentreront pas en
service d'ici
35 on se met dans notre travail là dans
la perspective qui a été arbitré à
Belfort de développement des pr et de 14
tranches depr d'ici 2035 parce que ça
aussi c'est une nouvelle donnée il y a
eu une
orientation il y a eu donc une
orientation qui a qui qui a été donnée
donc on s'est mis dans cette perspective
là et donc j'en profite madame pour
répondre à une de vos interpellations
sur le
mix oui dans futur énergétique 2050 nous
avons démontré qu'un mix qui comportait
du nouveau nucléaire avec les les
hypothèses de coût du nouveau nucléaire
que nous avons publié qui est de l'ordre
de 52 milliards d'euros des euros de
l'époque parce que depuis il y a eu il y
a eu un certain nombre il y a il y a
beaucoup d'actualisation à faire les
scénarios qui comportai du nouveau
nucléaire étai en coût complet pour la
collectivité moins onéreux que ceux qui
tendaient vers 100 % renouvelable
le coût complet pour la collectivité est
pas le seul paramètre qui compte dans la
décision politique et de toute façon ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas à nous et à force
à moi à donner mon avis sur une
éventuelle préférence technologique
simplement nous nous
documentons ces chemins et oui donc
effectivement dans futur énergétique
nous avons démontré qu'il y avait une
différence de coût complet pour la
collectivité je parle de coût et pas de
prix
de scénarios qui comportaient du nouveau
nucléaire donc on est toujours
euh dans dans ce scénario là et oui nous
avons pris comme
hypothèse l'option française retenue qui
était 14 pa
d'ici 2050 en faudrait-il plus je suis
pas sûr que la question se pose comme ça
madame la Présidente puis
que nous sommes à 14 p par an dans un
rythme
très important et nous atteignons
probablement des un certain nombre de
limites industrielles à les construire
d'ici 2050 parce que quand on dit 14 op
d'ici
2050 ce ce ne sont pas 14ep en cours de
construction ce sont 14ep qui sont
couplés au réseau et qui produisent tous
à leur puissance maximale donc c'est ça
le scénario retenu dans pour ceux qui
avaient lu futur énergé N02 et n03 et
oui nous avions fait l'hypothèse d'un
certain nombre de de SMR mis en service
d'ici
2050 cette hypothèse elle est toujours
valable conttenu des annonces qui ont
été faites par EDF et sur son projet New
World voilà donc de ce point de vuelà
rien ne change madame la président donc
j'ai été beaucoup trop long est-ce que
vous nous permettez de prendre des
minutes de plus pour vous parler un peu
d'économie ou oui allezy
oui voilà ce que je voulais vous dire
Thomas je te passe la parole sur des
sujets de flexibilité et puis sur des
sujets donc d'économie et de coût
puisque vous avez pointé ce
débat
madame merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs pour mettre l'accent également
sur quelques résultats importants de
l'étude les premiers sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
et l'équilibre en puissance du système
he puisqueil il sagit pas uniquement de
faire l'équilibre en énergie il faut
également équilibrer heure par heure
minute par
minute le premier résultat à court terme
c'est une perspective d'amélioration de
la situation en matière de sécurité
d'approvisionnement alors il est vrai
qu'on sort d'une période où au contraire
on a eu une augmentation du risque pour
des raisons structurelles dans un
premier temps avec deux grands facteurs
qui sont précisément documentés le
premier c'est la fermeture des centrales
au charbon et au fu euh depuis le un peu
avant les années 2010 et toute la
décennie 2010 donc ça c'était un
phénomène qui a été assez largement
anticipé dans les années 2010 et qui
s'est déroulé peu ou prou comme ce qu'on
pensait il y a 10 ans euh et le deuxème
le deuxème facteur structurel c'est la
dégradation de la disponibilité des
réacteurs nucléaires euh avant même la
situation de la crise de la corrosion
donc c'est plutôt euh la question euh de
la montée en charge des travaux de
prolongation des réacteurs euh et la
désorganisation des plannings liés au
covid donc ça ce facteur-là il a plus
pesé que ce qui était anticipé dans les
années 2010 ça ce sont les deux facteurs
structurels des années 2010 et puis il y
a aussi eu un facteur conjoncturel que
vous connaissez bien puisque c'est celui
de l'année 2022 qui est la crise en
France euh de la production de la
production nucléaire avec la corrosion
et on on le cite assez peu alors qu'en
fait c'est un phénomène structurant la
très faible production de l'hydraulique
l'année dernière qui était la plus
faible depuis
1976 donc voilà il y a plusieurs choses
qui qui qui qui ont joué euh alors la la
la crise sur le le nucléaire on est en
train d'en sortir au cours des
prochaines années il y a des mises en
service importantes qui sont annoncées
sur les renouvelables avec notamment
l'éolien Solair et aussi les gros parcs
en mer he qui arrivent maintenant et la
mise en service de l'pr ce qui fait que
à l'horizon 2025 on est sur une
perspective d'amélioration de la
situation en matière de sécurité
d'approvisionnement le point important
de notre analyse c'est l'horizon 2030
sur l'horizon 2030 moi j'en tirerai deux
grands enseignements le premier c'est
qu'il faut développer la flexibilité de
la demande et le stockage quand on parle
de flexibilité de la demande
concrètement qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
la capacité à moduler moduler c'est pas
supprimer c'est déplacer moduler de la
consommation d'une us usine d'un
électrolyseur qui produira de
l'hydrogène euh déplacer des charges de
voiture électrique de quelques heures
par jour si quelqu'un la branche à 20h
c'est probablement pas très structurant
que la le pic de recharge ait lieu entre
1h et 3h du matin ou entre 5h et 7h du
matin ça peut changer des choses pour le
système électrique et du stockage donc
ça c'est le premier c'est le premier
pilier l'analyse économique de ce pilier
elle est facile à faire elle est très
favorable parce sont des moyens qui sont
très peu coûteux le risque c'est que ça
reste une déclaration d'intention et
donc la proposition qu'on a faite dans
le bilan prévisionnel c'est un plan de
passage à l'échelle de ces flexibilités
du stockage qui reposerait sur trois axe
un le déploiement d'équipement par qu' a
priori dans notre programmation
énergétique on suit le nombre
d'éoliennes et panneaux solaires qu'on
installe on peut faire la même chose
pour les équipements connectés qui vont
permettre par exemple de faire cette
modulation la deuxème chose c'est la
renforçation des incitations économiques
et là on parle des grilles tarifaires et
la troisième chose qui qui nous semble
essentielle c'est de piloter de vérifier
l'effet agrégé de ces flexibilités on a
un seul juge de paix pour nous c'est la
courbe de consommation nationale
concrètement il faut qu'on soit en
mesure de faire des tests pour montrer
que ces flexibilité fonctionnent et
rendre un service équivalent à celui
d'un moyen de production donc ça ça
permet ces flexibilités le stockage ça
permet de gérer des problématiques qu'on
appelle courtes en matière de sécurité
d' ionnement donc de déplacer de
résoudre des problèmes de quelques
heures dans une journée c'est pas
suffisant parce que on peut avoir
également des épisodes comme des grandes
vagues de froid et ça ça dure pas
quelques heures ça dure plusieurs jours
consécutifs pour ça il faut d'autres
types de moyens il y a plusieurs
possibilités qui font le travail la
première c'est du nucléaire al comme il
y aura pas de réacteur en plus on parle
bien de la façon dont sont disponibles
les réacteurs actuels et donc 5 si on
arrive à avoir 55 GW de disponibilité du
parc tout l'hiver ce qui est des choses
qu'on avait dans les années 2010 alors
on a pas besoin de moyens
supplémentaires la deuxième possibilité
c'est de combiner le niveau haut de
sobriété que Xavier piéchasi qui a
appelé la sobriété structurelle et le
niveau le plus haut de déploiement des
énergies renouvelables là encore vous
réduisez votre besoin et donc on
respecte nos critères en matière de
sécurité d'approvisionnement il y aurait
une troisème option qui fait le travail
ça serait d'avoir plus de moyens
hydrauliques réversible ça s'appelle ces
fameuses step avec des grands barrages
la faculté d'y arriver d'ici 2030 dans
les dans les dans les volumes
nécessaires est quand
même questionnable voilà donc on l'a
mentionné parce que je voudrais pas
qu'on tire de notre étude que c'est pas
une option qui est
techniquement possible en
revanche SEM quand même peu crédible de
compter uniquement là-dessus sinon il y
a les fameux moyens thermiques là il y a
encore trois soussutions la première
c'est de faire comme certains de nos
voisins ou garder quelques centrale
thermique fu charbon vous les mettez en
réserve concrètement elles ne peuvent
plus fonctionner sauf en cas de péril
imminent la deuxième c'est de garder les
dernières centrales au charbon mais de
les convertir avec d'autres combustibles
décarbonés notamment la biomasse avec la
question de savoir si on si on il faut
quand même qu'elle fonctionne assez peu
pour pas trop pu dans le gisement de
biomasse dans ce cas-là et la troisème
option c'est d'avoir des nouveaux moyens
thermiques mais dans ce cas d'emblé
décarboné et adapté au besoins du
système c'est-àdire sont pas des
centrales à gaz actuell sont des
centrales qui devraient fonctionner à un
très faible nombre d'heures et qui
pourrait d'emblé fonctionner avec du
biofule du biométhane ou de l'hydrogène
ce sont les trois possibilités mais
elles sont on en aurait besoin dans des
volumes limités et encore une fois si on
coche une des cases
sur le nucléaire le le doublé sobriété
ENR max ou l'hydraulique on n pas besoin
de cette solution dans notre dans notre
scénario de référence ça c'est sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement je dois
dire un mot de la façon dont on a
modélisé et des enseignements qu'on a
tiré sur la relation entre la France et
les pays voisins européens en terme de
méthode ce qui est structurant que vous
ayez en tête RTE analyse une France
interconnectée avec les pays voisin he
parce que c'est la réalité
opérationnelle du système que nous
opérons et on a testé différentes
hypothèses parce que là encore les pays
voisins sont comme les nôtres ils se
posent des questions sur leur
trajectoire de transition alors on en
quelques anenseignnement le premier une
un haut niveau quand même de euh de de
certitude sur le fait que
l'interconnexion a apporté des bénéfices
considérables au cours des dernières
années en matière de sécurité
d'approvisionnement parce qu'on a mis en
ensemble des systèmes électriques qui
avent pas du tout les mêmes profils de
risque donc en les couplant et ben on a
amélioré la résilience de chacun d'entre
eux et finalement ça a eu pour effet de
gommer les conséquences techniques des
spécificités nationales euh ça sera
quand même deuxième enseignement moins
le cas à l'avenir pourquoi parce qu'en
fait tous les pays européens vont faire
peu ou prou la même chose ils vont
déployer à court terme de l'éolien et du
solaire donc il y a des modes communs ce
qui explique qu'on est prudent sur la
por futur des interconnexions en matière
de sécurité d'approvisionnement et qu'on
considère que les besoins de flexibilité
dont la France a besoin ils vont
beaucoup reposer sur ce qu'on développe
en France alors ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas faire de nouvelles
interconnexions au contraire on en aura
besoin pour importer de temps en temps
et pour exporter la plupart du temps
l'interconnexion a un très bon bilan
économique et carbone la mesure où si on
parvient à déployer notre parc de
production
la France restera un grand exportateur
d'électricité elle le redevient en 2023
et il faut savoir que ces exports comme
la France a un parc de production
d'électricité très décarboné ces exports
conduisent réellement à une réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre à
l'échelle de l'Europe donc c'est un bon
rendement
carbone sur sur la question
économique pour finir donc le contexte
général c'est bien celui que vous avez
rappelé madame la Présidente en
introduction sui de la réduction des
imports de pétrole et de gaz donc votre
5e question vous vous avez demandé si on
pouvait faire mieux que 5 à 10 milliards
d'euros de réduction de la facture
fossile j'aurais tendance à dire que ce
serait bien déjà de parvenir à 5 à 10
milliards parce que on va quand même pas
changer de modèle énergétique en un
claquement de doigt et que même si même
si finalement le débat français a été
très polarisé par les questions du mix
électrique renouvelable et nucléaire la
réalité de notre notre situation
énergétique c'est que nous dépendons à
60 % des énergies fossiles et que dans
le système dans le scénario a nous
réduisons déjà de manière 2000 d'ici
2030 et 2035 considérablement cette
dépendance et en fait on arriverait à
économiser 190 milliards d'euros sur
l'ensemble de la période pour les
imports de pétrole et de gaz fossil
alors ça nécessite il faut pas le cacher
des investissements qui sont massifs
dans le secteur de la production lors de
grandeur par rapport à la décennie 2010
en matière d'investissement c'est un
triplement du
rythme ce chiffre est pas totalement
nouveau puisqu'on l'avait déjà dans les
futurs énergétiques 2050 simplement la
séquence d'investissement est plus
concentrée sur la période 2020-2030 ou
2025-235 là encore c'est mécanique
puisque on a des objectifs climatiques
qui sont rapprochés en 2030 puisque on
veut
réindustrialiser choses qui sont
absolument souhaitable bah il faut
investir il faut y aller plus vite et
donc on a ce ce
triplement c'est beaucoup mais même dans
ce contexte la France garde un mix
compétitif à l'échelle européenne
l'indicateur clé pour nous c'est le coût
de production à long terme du système ce
coût de ce coût de production il évolue
un petit peu il augmente un petit peu
entre 2020 et 2025 pourquoi parce que le
coût du nucléire augmente parce qu'on
met en service un certain nombre de
têtes de série hein que ce soit les les
les parc en en mer que ce soit le Pr de
flamandville donc c'est à ce moment-là
que ça intègre la chronique de coût en
revanche ensuite comme on met en service
des énergies renouvelables qui sont
compétitives par rapport au système ce
coût moyen de production est stable ou
légèrement baissier et donc tout ça
montre que la France avec cette
stratégie énergétique conserve une
trajectoire d'évolution du mix sur son
fondamental économique qui est tout à
fait contrôlé alors pour finir tout ça
ça nous dit dit rien des prix on
considère toujours indispensable d'avoir
une d'avoir une des éléments de réforme
les prix sur les marchés de gros eux ils
vont demeurer assez
durablement régis par les équilibres
européens et dans ces équilibres
européens il y a souvent des centrales
fossiles qui sont appelés de l'ordre de
3/4 du temps même dans une vision à à à
moyen terme ça veut dire qu'en fait il y
aura toujours une sensibilité de ces
prix sur le marché de gros au prix du
gaz et donc ça veut dire que dès que le
prix du gaz sera élevé les prix des
marché de gros d'électricité seront
élevés et c'est la raison pour lequelle
on considère que il faut garder ce qui
fonctionne ce qui fonctionne c'est
l'interconnexion technique du système
c'est les signaux de prix de court terme
qui donnent les incitations au produ au
bon moment et corriger ce qui est un
problème c'est-à-dire donner de la
visibilité et permettre d'avoir des
engagements de long terme que ce soit
par des régulation publi ou des contrats
privés donc voilà j'aurais pu parler
aussi de l'industrie l' l'hydrogène du
chauffage ou de la mobilité
mais je n'ai pas le temps ou des ou de
ce qu'il y aura à faire aussi sur le
réseau qui fait face aux mêmes
problématiques industrielles et aux
mêmes type d'inflexion mais ça c'est
plutôt pour l'année 2024 qu'on prépare
le le schéma directeur mais voilà pour
clore ce propos
liminire merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président et Monsieur de vos propos
liminires qui sont déjà extrêmement
complets alors on a énormément de
questions même si monsieur le Président
de RTE nous a dit qu'il était à notre
disp
voilà pour l'ensemble des questions et
donc la matinée mais nous avons aussi
des amendements examiner dans le cadre
du projet de loi négociation commercial
qui sera examiné demain en séance donc
on va essayer d'être assez concis je
vais laisser la parole à quatre
rapporteurs qui soit sur des projets de
loi soit sur des missions d'information
ont eu à traiter de toute partie des
sujets que vous avez évoqué avec nous
donc leur demande à eux aussi d'être
assez concis ensuite on vous laissera
leur répondre et on ouvrira
la discussion à l'ensemble de nos
collègues qui sont très très nombreux
donc là aussi s'il y a des redondances
de questions je vous demande
d'abandonner les questions qui auraient
déjà été posées ou auxquelles on aurait
pu déjà apporter des réponses et d'être
en tout cas très concis dans la question
posée donc on va demander à Daniel
gréiller à Patrick Chauvet Jean-Jacques
Michot et Fabien Guay de poser leurs
questions et d'être relativement
synthétique merci Daniel gréier
oui merci Madame présidente monsieur le
président chers
collègues en complément des questions
qui ont été posées par notre Présidente
il y en a une qui concerne la différence
d'appréciation entre vos propos et les
annonces de la ministre de la transition
énergétique sur la future
PPE en effet a annoncé une
multiplication total de deux voire par
trois du solaire et une augmentation
annuelle de 2 GW de l'éolien vous nous
avez fait part tout à l'heure d'un
niveau nécessaire bien bien supérieur
donc ce serait effectivement assez
intéressant de de voir comment tout ça
peut être cohérent euh puisque nous
aurons à nous prononcer dans cette
future PPE euh il y a aussi une question
par rapport à la capacité énergétique
sur le nucléaire donc là aussi vous avez
fait part des des 360
euh mais faut pas oublier que nous
étions à 280 terwh en 2022 euh donc là
encore le le décalage quand même très
important comme la présidente a demandé
qu'on soit plus court et bien je vais un
peu massacrer mon intervention je
voudrais vous interroger sur la question
de de l'hydrogène que vous avez pas
évoqué et effectivement le sujet de
l'hydroélectricité qui nous donne une
capacité de production très intéressante
et je vous remercie d'avoir évoqué les
steps euh qui pourrait être très
complémentairire àé auien et au
photovoltaïque et malgré
tout être capable de de créer et d'être
plus offensif sans pour autant créer de
nouvelles réserves les steps peuvent se
réaliser dans un temps lapse de temps
bien plus court concernant l'hydrogène
je voudrais connaître votre point de vue
sur la stratégie on a deux stratégies
complètement différentes l'Allemagne qui
a décidé plutôt de d'importer
l'hydrogène et la France qui considère
qu'il est nécessaire plutôt de la
produire sur notre territoire
et puis une question là aussi sur le
domaine de l'hydrogène faut-il la
réserver à l'industrie ou au transport
trème
question concernant les investissements
qui sont nécessaires pour réaliser
concrètement la transition énergétique
d'
RTE vous avez estimé de porter ces
investissements annuels de 25 à 35
milliards d'euros il y a il y a aussi
une vraie question puisque chaque région
suite à la loi qui a été votée est en
train de définir son schéma énerg du
futur énergétique euh et du transport
des énergies renouvelables qui vont se
développer sur les territoires et qui
n'a pas pour autant été imaginé et pour
avoir présidé pendant 12 ans le comité
de concertation pour la région Lorine je
sais que entre le moment où on décide de
créer une nouvelle ligne et le moment où
elle est effectivement construite il se
passe quelques temps donc tout ça
comment ça peut s'articuler euh il y a
aussi le problème du cûp et je voudrais
surtout vous entendre sur la réforme
européen en cours tel que sur le marché
d'électricité la taxonomie verte
européenne ou l'industrie zéro émission
sont-elles à la hauteur quant à la place
accordée à l'énergie nucléaire et quel
est votre avis sur le débat national en
cour sur au dispositif de régulation
devant succéder à l'accès régulé
l'électricité nucléaire votre étude
estimant que le dispositif actuel ne
couvre pas les cûts de l'opérateur et
qu' protège peu les consommateurs des
prix je rappelle que quedf évalue ses
coûts à
74,8 € par
mgawh alors que sur la période 2026-230
contre 60,7 pour la creux qu'en est-il
de votre position au niveau d RTE enfin
4è lieu pouvez-vous nous indiquer l'état
de la sûreté d'approvisionnement donc
vous l'avez évoqué donc je raccourcis là
aussi par contre quel est le moyen de
sécurité que vous pouvez apporter
sachant que les moyens que vous avez
estimé et hélas vous avez raison quand
je dis hélas parce que le temps est
court pour construire des centrales
nucléaires nouvelles on sait tous qu'on
a eu le mois de décembre 2021 faut pas
l'oublier ou en décembre le
photovoltaïque a une production limitée
et que lorsque vous avez un temps calme
les éoliennes elles tournent pas trop et
que le schéma et là encore je vous
remercie de l'analyse de
l'interconnexion absolument essentielle
au niveau européen mais dès lors que
tous les pays sont sur de renouvelables
éolien et
photovoltaïque la la notion de de temps
est déterminante et et donc là aussi
comment envisagez-vous cette sécurité
par rapport ce risque de conditions
climatiqu et enfin la la la question
aussi que je voulais vous poser euh
concerne le cadre législatif fixé par le
le nouveau cléire le nouveau nucléaire
qui a intégré les ouvrages de
raccordement au réseau de
transport au réacteur nucléaire
bénéficiant de souplesse administrative
et celuisu de la loi pouvoir d'achat du
16 août 2022 qui a confié au
gestionnaires de réseau de transport
certaines compétences pour valoriser les
effacements ou réquisitionner les
stockages voilà madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président chers collègues
les question que je souhaitais vous
poser en m'excusant d'avoir été préférez
répondre tout de suite à Monsieur Grier
d'accordoui puisque peut-être que au
passage je ferai des réponses d'autres
d'autres questions de de sénatrices ou
de sénateurs qui sont en attente très
rapidement monsieur
grimet les volumes
affichés par Madame panierunaché sont
compatibles avec les ordres deendeur que
nous avons donné sur le renouvelable que
ce soit du photovoltaïque
ou ou de l'éolien terrestre et par
définition je vous ai dit que nous avvez
qu'on avait repris à notre compte
l'objectif de 18 GW d'éolien offshore en
2035 donc par définition c'est
exactement le même chiffre donc oui
c'est compatible en rythme de croissance
annuelle et en en rythme d'installation
de nouvelles installation chaque année
et c'est compatible avec la cible de ce
que ça doit produire en
électricité tous les
ans sur le nucléaire oui vous avez
raison la la production était largement
en dessous de de 300 tawh l'an dernier
du fait essentiellement de la corrosion
sous contrainte mais le parc nucléaire
subit subira un certain nombre
d'opérations de maintenance et de
réinvestissement ce qu'on appelait le
grand carénage dans les années qui
viennent ce qui conduit à baisser un peu
légèrement sa disponibilité moyenne
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
pris cette hypothèse prudente de de 360
taw de production d'énergie nucléaire
moyenne par an nous n'y sommes pas
encore mais là on se projette à 2030 et
2035 et là il est tout à fait
raisonnable de se projeter dans ce
monde-là j'insiste hein que nous avons
bien dit que retrouver le rythme de
production nucléaire historique qui
était de 400 TWh était une cible qui
était souhaitable d'atteindre c'est ça
reste
souhaitable bon mais euh notre boulot
aussi à nous c'est de tester des mondes
dans lesquels on n'arrive pas à ces
objectifs là et et c'est la raison pour
la laquelle on a pris cet objectif
prudent et là on revient sur la
discussion qu'on a eu tout à l'heure sur
bah de quels moyen de production
d'énergie renouvelable complémentaire
nous avons besoin
et et nous pouvons
développer puisque je parle de de de
nucléaire oui on a dans la loi
d'accélération du nucléaire
euh la loi d'accélération du nucléaire
nous permet d'accélérer le raccordement
de ces nouvelle centrale
nucléaire je crois que c'est c'est de
bonnes politiques de manière
systématique un moyen de production qui
n'est pas raccordé il sert à rien euh on
il il faut pas qu'on se retrouve dans un
monde dans lequel
euh le réseau structurellement serait
soumis à des procédures qui le ferait
aller plus doucement que la manière dont
les nouveaux moyens de production se
développent que ce soit du nouveau
nucléaire ou que ce soit des énergies
renouvelables c'est la raison pour
laquelle dans l'autre texte la loi
la loi aper les S3R ENR c'était votre
question monsieur grimier ont été
réformé pour que ces schémas qui nous
permettent à nous de faire les bons
investissements au bon moment soit mise
à jour plus vite plus efficacement et
plus pragmatiquement pour que nous nous
puissions bénéficier d'une planification
le réseau c'est un gros appareil
industriel qui a besoin d'être planifié
il faut qu'on arrive à planif à donner
de la visibilité à ce qu'on ait de la
visibilité sur les futurs raccordements
en matière d'offshore il faut qu'on ait
de la
visibilité sur sur le raccordement des
ENR terrestres c'est la condition pour
qu'on puisse être à
l'URE il y a des cas et c'est de plus en
plus fréquent où nous nous prenons nos
où nous faisons aussi des
investissements par anticipation et ce
et c'est ce que nous avons fait
pour être à l'heure sur les grandes
zones de décarbonation française je veux
vous le dire on n'attend pas les bras
Ballan de bénéficier d'une planification
qui s'agisse de la production ou de la
consommation nous savions qu'il y avait
des grands besoin don
d'approvisionnement d'électricité à
dunkererque à fosse au Havre et dans la
vallée de la chimie nous avons pris sur
nous de faire des investissement par
anticipation pour que le réseau de
transport d'électricité soit à l'heure
des industriel qui a besoin de
s'électrifier 15 GW de raccordement
supplémentaire ordre de grandeur de
cette anticipation d'investissement pour
l'entreprise que j'ai l'honneur de
présider entre 1,5 et 2 milliards
d'euros donc nous le faisons mais il est
vrai que de manière générale plus la
France se dotera d'une
planification en matière de production
d'énergie qui nous permettra de voir
loin plus le réseau sera là à
temps le réseau c'est c'est un réseau de
coupt fixe il se répercute finé sur le
consommateur je crois qu'il est de notre
devoir commun que cette plénification en
plus elle permette le maximum de
mutualisation puisque tout ça finit dans
la facture des entreprises et des
Français et donc cette planification
elle nous donne de la visibilité elle
nous permet d'être à l'heure mais elle
nous permet aussi de mutualiser
l'infrastructure et tout le monde
comprend que c'est beaucoup plus
intelligent de mutualiser
une infrastructure pour cette
industrielle plutôt que d'en construire
une pour chacun parce qu'à la fin c'est
dans la facture des Français Thomas un
mot sur l'hydrogène et sur la sur
l'hydro et sur la sécurité
d'pr sur
l'hydraulique la perspective pour nous
c'est bien une augmentation légère du du
de la capacité de production légère
parce
que même si on il y a aucun doute sur le
fait que les investissements hydraiques
ils ont une très grande valeur
socio-économique pour le pays sur chaque
projet on sait qu'il y aura un débat
local sur l'incidence environnementale
donc c'est c'est assez logique je pense
pas que ça va
se on est certain qu'on peut pas en un
claquement de Doig augmenter
considérablement la capacité hydraulique
ensuite même si on augmente la capacité
technique de production à la pointe on
voit une stabilité du productible
pourquoi 1 il y a l'influence du
changement climatique alors qui à court
terme change plutôt le moment où il y
aura de la production hydraulique
puisque fond des neiges anticipé égal
égale hydraulique plus précoce égale
période été début d'automne avec
vraiment des productibles hydrauliques
en baisse et aussi modélisation des
conflits d'usage sur l'eau qu'on intègre
maintenant à nos analyses ça c'est sur
l'hydraulique et sur l'hydrogène
effectivement il y a quand même deux
modèles très différents qui sont en
train de se mettre en place en Europe
Europe modèle de notre de nos voisins
allemands c'est le modèle de l'import
mais je pense que vu les choix
énergétiques qu'ils ont fait de toute
façon c'est l'import d'hydrogène est
essentiel à leur
stratégie le la la stratégie française
est de produire l'essentiel de
l'hydrogène sur le territoire national
ce qui est possible si le prix de
l'électricité est maintenue donc par
exemple pour que l'hydrogène français
soit compé par rapport à des à des de la
des des imports il faudrait que vu de
l'électrolyseur l'approvisionnement soit
de l'ordre de 50 60 € du mgawh c'est pas
le prix moyen c'est le moment où il
consomme c'estàd qu'en fait s'il ne
consomme pas quand les prix sont élevés
bah leur prix moyen est plus bas donc ça
veut dire que il y a un espace hein pour
la production d'hydrogène en France euh
en revanche il faut pas nier qu'il y a
la possibilité de concurrence par les
imports euh pas tellement d'ailleurs ou
moins sur l'hydrogène plus sur les
carburants de synthèse qui sont des
dérivés de l'hydrogène parce que les
carburants de synthèse qui sont
acheminables par bateau par exemple bah
vous pouvez le le transport est moins
onéreux et donc l'espace économique pour
produire massivement en France de la des
des carburants de synthèse il est quand
même vraiment soumis à une très forte
compétitivité prix pas seulement coût
prix du électrique
français voilà merci et pour finir
monsieur gréiller il est impossible de
d'avoir un un avis sur les les débats
qui sont en cours entre DF et le
gouvernement sur le
mode de régulation ce n'est pas notre
rôle ce que nous pouvons vous dire c'est
ce que Thomas verin vous a dit tout à
l'heure c'est que si nous si nous
voulons électrifier massivement nos
usages il faut que nous trouvions dans
dans le pays des moyens pour que les
prix se rapprochent progressivement des
coûts de production puisqueen France
nous avons des coûts de production
plutôt compétitifs et que de ce point de
vue il y a plusieurs outils qui existent
le contrat à long terme à à PP ou des
modes plus régulatoires nous on ne peut
pas se prononcer sur l'un ou l'autre de
de ces leviers en revanche ce que nous
pouvons dire c'est que si nous voulons
nous électrifier et rentré dans cette
électrification que l'on est que l'on
décrit alors oui du point de vue des
prix il faut que la
France se mette dans un système qui fait
que les prix d'électricité vu du
consommateur final est tendance
progressivement à se rapprocher des
coûts simple question d'incitation
économique à quitter le pétrole et le
gaz fossile pour
s'électrifier merci alors Patrick
Chauvet qui a été rapporteur sur le
projet de loi énergie renouvelable
ensuite Jean-Jacques Michot sur la
mission d'information nucléaire et
hydrogène et enfin Fabien Guay qui éit
rapporteur sur la mission mieux prévenir
et mieux lutter contre la fraude à
l'arinene merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues à mon tour je voudrais
compléter les questions posées par notre
présidente sur deux points tout d'abord
pouvez-vous faire le point sur les
investissements liés à la transition
énergétique pris en charge par RTE en
juin dernier vous aviez indiqué au Sénat
investir 2 milliards d'euros pour
l'année 2023 constatant un fort
engouement des projets de raccordement
autour des grands ports industriel tels
que dunkererc faus surmer Le Havre et
Lyon pour preuve ont dénombré 12 GW de
projets d'électrolyseurs d'hydrogène dès
2023 soit bien au-delà de l'objectif de
6,5 gigwh d'ici 2030 fixé par la
stratégie nationale hydrogène pour
autant l'essentiel de ces projets était
au stade de la décision d'investissement
et non de l'autorisation
d'investissement où en est-on
aujourd'hui et qu'en est-il des autres
projets de ce type également dans la loi
énergie renouvelable du 10 mars 2023 ou
encore le projet de loi industrie verte
dont l'examen parlementaire s'est achevé
RTE a été doté de facilités pour les
raccordements des projets liés à la
transition énergétique ainsi pour les
énergies renouvelables le premier texte
a permis de passer d'une logique premier
arrivée premier servi à une faculté de
réorganisation des priorités
avec l'introduction d'un ordre de
classement et la révision des schémas
régionaux de raccordement au réseau des
énergies renouvelables de plus des
dérogation au droits de l'urbanisme au
droits de l'environnement ou au droits
de l'énergie ont été prévu pour le
recardement de certains projets
industriels ou renouvelablebl je pense
aux dispenses liées aux règles de
construction en loi littorale à
l'autorisation de construction de ligne
électrique ou à la procédure de
participation du public ce cadre
législative est-il adapté et est-il
appliqué je je vous remercie
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président chers collègues dans votre
bilan prévisionnel monsieur le Président
RTE a indiqué que l'accélération des
pompes à chaleur ne conduit pas à
augmenter sensiblement la consommation
d'électricité ni la pointe de
consommation électrique et qu'elle
permet à contrario d'améliorer la
souveraineté énergétique de la France et
les émissions de gaz à effet de ser
comment arrivez-vous à ces résultats
tenez-vous compte du coût de cette
transition en particulier pour les
copropriétaires et les bailleurs sociaux
dans la mesure où les chaudières à gaz
représentent les 3/4 du marché collectif
et tenez-vous compte de l'impact de
cette transition en particulier sur la
filière des chaudières à gaz qui
mobilise 36 usines pour leur fabrication
et 15000 entreprises pour leur
installation les les pom chaleur hybride
ne peuvent-elles pas constituer un bon
compromis pour maîtriser davantage la
pointe de consommation électrique et
limiter les coûts de l'installation dans
la mesure où ell permettent de conserver
une alimentation au gaz potentiellement
de sources renouvelables je vous
remercie merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président juste un point vos
rapports sont toujours d'extrême
qualité euh ils doivent nous faire
réfléchir comme vos propos moi je crois
qu'on a une question c'est continu
àcarboner notre mix énergétique donc
l'électrification est un un point
d'appui euh et je crois que nous avons
une question c'est que il va falloir
lourdement investir dans tous les
systèmes de production le nucléaire ça
prend 15 ans à sortir de terre donc il y
a une question c'est le renouvelable
extrêmement fortement et ça doit nous
inviter aussi à réfléchir à la question
industrielle parce que moi je veux bien
des sites de production notamment sur
les énergies renouvelables mais
j'aimerais qu'on les construise aussi en
France ou en tout cas au sein de l'Union
européenne et juste une question sur la
pointe dans votre rapport je vois pas
comment je l'ai pas lu mais peut-être
que vous allez m'éclairer je vois pas
comment on passe les les pointes l'hiver
sans pilotable et sans se passer
aujourd'hui je dis bien aujourd'hui du
gaz et du charbon sur la question
électrique le 2è point je vais très vite
euh on a un débat vous dites vous faites
pas de politique si vous en faites parce
que vous dites sur le marché européen on
a deux questions c'est soit les PPA soit
les contrats euh pour différence
d'ailleurs le marché européen n'a rien
inventé hein contre rapport différent
c'est Henri progliot sur la question du
nucléaire londonien comme d'ailleurs le
coût marginal c'est pas le marché
européen qui l' inventé c'est Marcel
Boiteux qui vient de décéder d'ailleurs
euh donc je vous ai bien entendu on peut
on peut sortir du marché européen et
continuer les interconnexions désolé le
marché européen c'est 97 les
interconnexions c'est 67 donc moi je
vois pas comment d com il y a un
désalignement du prix du marché du coû
de production comment on fait en restant
dans le marché aujourd'hui là il faut
m'expliquer et donc il y a une troisième
voie c'est pour ça que je vous dis que
vous faites la politique parce que
autrement il y a la question de revenir
à un service public unifié intégré et
d'ailleurs RTE revenant dans le giron de
DF en on peut inventer un nouveau nom
hein moi je dis gedf groupe énergie de
France où on nationaliserait EDF total
énergie et et NG donc il y a une
question mais elle est posée parce que
la question du prix
elle va être massive pour les
populations si on passe par exemple un
prix à reen de 42 € à 70 ou 80 ou 90 les
factures vont continuer à augmenter et
il y a déjà 12 millions de précaires
énergétiques dans ce pays voyez donc bon
en total désaccord avec vous vous l'avez
compris sur cette question et la
troisième je vais vite c'est sur l'arine
on a fait une super mission
d'information et madame la Présidente
euh on on appelle à élargir les abus
d'aren à renforcer les obligations
fournisseurs à améliorer la protection
et et l'information pour le consommateur
et les consommatrices qu'en pensez-vous
et puis on a découvert quelque chose RTE
évidemment un besoin spécifique d'aren
euh nous nous proposons même que vous
l'ayez que vous le conserviez sans
passer par un fournisseur est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette
proposition voilà je vous
remercie monsieur le Président c'est à
vous on va essayer d'accélérer
euh je vais prendre la question sur les
investissements oui aujourd'hui nous
dépensons 2 milliards d'euros par an sur
le réseau chez RTE ces investissements
par an ils vont dépasser 4 milliards
d'ici 2030 donc la croissance est
absolument considérable euh donc enedis
le principal distributeur a déjà euh
rendu publi un C nombre de ses
trajectoires d'investissement d'ici 2040
pour notre part nous le rendrons public
et nous serons heureux si nous sommes
réinvités de venir vous en rendre compte
dans cette même salle au début de
l'année 2024 pourquoi parce que nous
avons besoin de la PPE du gouvernement
avant d'en tirer les conclusions sur les
investissements qu'il faut faire sur
Réau de transport euh bon tout le monde
comprend ça on fait des rapports
prospectifs on essaie d'éclairer le et
la décision publique euh vous
[Musique]
euh les assemblées le gouvernement sont
responsables des choix qui sont faits à
l'issue de ces documents et d'autres
documents voilà il faudra qu'il qu' a
une PPE qui nous donne avoir un certain
nombre de choix notamment de production
à la suite de quoi nous serons capables
de venir rendre compte devant vous d'un
programme d'investissement de RTE d'ici
2040 qui soit précis parce qu'on vous
doit cette précision mais mais th
maladie ces investissements seront
considérables de toute façon nous le
savons déjà vous avez pointé les
questions de facilités qui nous sont
données par des par différentes lois qui
concernne l'accélération des procédures
la
capacité à déroger donc à la loi
littorale euh j'y ai partiellement
répondu je voudrais dire que si nous
voulons nous électrifier vite c'est pas
que de la production qu'il faut mettre
en œuvre en France c'est du réseau plus
d'électricité égale plus
d'électrification égale plus de prod
mais plus de réseau et donc ça il faut
que tout le monde
l'entende donc c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup de c'est
beaucoup d'investissement pour nous mais
c'est aussi surtout je veux que vous
entendiez ça une course contre la montre
et donc cette course contre la montre on
la gère aussi en simplifiant des
procédures et et en nous permettant
d'aller plus vite dans les phases àont
et de pas passer 5 ans dans des phases
d'autorisation ça relève de la logique
de la planification de la logique de la
mutualisation pour que le système
électrique coûte moins cher et bien
évidemment c'est l'enjeu pour que nous
soyons à l'heure donc monsieur le
sénateur oui ce cadre est adapté à nos
yeux pour le
moment je souhaite pas répondre monsieur
Guay sur
euh
sur les discussions je l'ai déjà dit
vous il est de notoriété publique il y a
des discussions entre le gouvernement et
le et EDF aujourd'hui sur ce qui se
substituera à l'arène donc moi je
souhaite pas du tout prendre parti ce
n'est pas mon travail de prendre une
position dans ce ce débat
oui RTE achète de l'électricité pour
compenser les pertes il revient au
gouvernement et à votre et à votre
assemblée de voter les textes qui nous
donnera ou pas donc accès à ces volumes
d'énergie ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que de toute façon les p CER c'est les
consommateurs qui les compensent à la
fin sur leur facture donc c'est un choix
c'est un choix qui revient à l'exécutive
mais comme Madame primal disait ce ne
sera de toute façon pas de l'argent
magique je laisse Thomas dire un mot sur
la pointe et les packs puisque là nous
avons la même question comment est-ce
qu'on passe la pointe dans un monde plus
électrifié avec moins de gaz faossile je
rappelle que dans le monde dans lequel
on se projette il y a beaucoup de biogaz
donc il ne il ne s'agit pas de faire
disparaître l'usage du gaz on parle
toujours bien le gaz Faussier oui je
pense qu'il faut commencer par là en
réalité les stratégies de décarbonation
dans le secteur du bâtiment qu'on a
regardé sont des stratégies qui allisent
systématiquement le déploiement des
pompes à chelleur qui sont des solutions
utilisant des énergies renouvelables des
situation des solutions qui sont très
efficaces d'un point de vue énergétique
le fait d'utiliser Davant age de
biométhane dans la dans la dans le dans
les chaudières à gaz actuels le
raccordement au réseau de chaleur urbain
et le bois énergie sur les pompes à
chaleur l'impact sur la consommation
d'électricité moyenne est effectivement
très faible puisquen réalité le
rendement d'une pompe à chaleur est
extrêmement élevé et la la très grande
majorité du temps une pompe à chaleur ça
un coefficient de performance très
supérieur à 1 de l'ordre de c'est c'est
trois fois plus efficace qu'une qu'une
chaudière qu'une chaudière donc
forcément ça a un impact qui est très
minime sur la consommation d'électricité
par contre on n pas du tout dit qu'il y
avait pas d'impact sur la pointe on a
dit qu'il y avait un impact on a dit que
d'ici 2030 l'impact il était l'heord de
6 Gow dans le scénario central et en
réalité selon les
analyses selon les scénarios ça peut
être moins ou ça peut même être plus
tout dépend de la façon dont vont se
combiner euh don don don dont on va se
du type de de pompe à chaleur qu'on va
installer et de la rénovation des
logements nous on a été plutôt prudent
dans l'analyse un on intgle l'effet
rebond rénovation énergétique égal effet
rebond parce que une partie les ménages
utilisent une partie du gain non pas
pour baisser leur facture mais pour
augmenter la température de leur
logement on le sait on l'intègre dans
notre modélisation de même si on
souhaite et si on accélère à fond sur la
rénovation thermique et notamment la
rénovation efficace c'est pas vrai que
en quelques années ça va produire des
effets massifs on voit les effets mais
dans le temps notamment entre 2030 et
2035 c'est pour ça que dans notre
analyse il y a une pointe qui augmente
d'ici 2030 après là il y a pas de doute
sur la sur l'impact climatique vaut
mieux utiliser une pompe à chaleur qui
utilise de l'électricité et de temps en
temps cette électricité est carbonée
qu'utilisit pendant tout l'hiver une
énergie fossile en fait CO2 on l'a fait
très proprement y compris en intégrant
ce qui se passe dans les pays voisins et
on confirme les résultats qu'on avait
déjà publié avec laadem en 2020 le bilan
carbone de tout cela est positif et bien
sûr pour les pompes à chaleur comme pour
les chaudières comme pour tout il y a un
un intérêt majeur à ce que davantage de
ces composants soit fabriqués en France
et en Europe là il y a pas du tout de
doute et nous on s'inscrit dans ce
mouvement dans notre dans notre analyse
mouvement qu'on a également essayé de
chiffrer dans les dans les analyses
économiques donc ça c'est pour la partie
pompe à chaleur et sur la partie
européenne qui une
question difficile voire quasiment
redoutable ce qui est important c'est
que dans le système européen les outils
du marché court terme et les outils de
la sécurité d'approvisionnement de
l'interconnexion sont totalement
imbriqués ils sont imbriqués avec un
système oui oui mais
je mais je j'en suis parfaitement
conscient néanmoins et nous l'avons dit
dit à chaque fois qu'il y a eu un paquet
européen à chaque fois notamment lors du
troisème paquet notamment lors du clean
energy package on a dit attention
derrière ces dispositions techniques il
y a une imbrication extrêmement
puissante des systèmes sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement et honnêtement je
peux pas dire que nos alertes a
systématiquement été entendu dit
autrement ces pointslà et c'est encore
le cas potentiellement vous avez entendu
parler de la réforme du Market design en
cours pour vous c'est PPE et CFD il y a
des dispositions sur la fenêtre
temporelle d'action du gestionnaire de
réseau de transport qui s'en
occupe donc ce système nous en tant
coopérateur en tant qu'exploitant du
système électrique on peut vous dire que
l'imbrication a été extrêmement
puissante et que il est aujourd'hui
extrêmement techniquement difficile de
les les départir nous ce qu'on veut
c'est sauvegarder ce qu' fonctionne bien
et ce qui fonctionne bien c'est
l'interconnexion technique entre les
États-membres et le système d'incitation
à court terme on pense que les règles
communes européennes en réalité les
règles d'exploitation elles nous
protègent et le fait que ça ne soit pas
des achats entre d'état à état et
quelque chose qui a
protégé les opérateurs lors de l'hiver
dernier en fait contrairement à ce qu'on
dit la France n'achète n'a pas acheté de
l'électricité à l'Allemagne l'hiver
dernier c'est pas ça qui s'est passé de
la même façon que nous ne vendons pas
d'électricité à l'Allemagne en en ce
moment ce sont des opérateurs qui
exploitent dans un système de règles
communes que nous avons contribué à
écrire dans le cadre qui a été fixé par
les directives donc sortir de ce
système n'est pas évident mais je peux
vous garantir monsieur le sénateur une
chose vous verrez que comme on publie
les chapitres détaillés du du du du
bilan prévisionnel à peu près au rythme
d'un par semaine sur la partie
économique vous verrez que toutes les
propositions qui ont été faites lors de
la concertation y compris celle que vous
avez relayé ont été analysé honnête sur
sur sur exactement la même trame encore
une fois nous ce que nous disons c'est
que le système d'interconnexion
technique qui est celui qui fait
fonctionner la machine européenne et
impérativement à sauvegarder tant il est
vital à notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement j'ajoute que nous
avons démontré que les interconnexions
avec les échanges comme le disait Thomas
entre des opérateurs entre des acteurs
économiques c'est pas les États qui
s'échangent des volumes d'énergie he
c'est les acteurs économiques
indépendants qui utilise des
interconnexions si c'est un marché
libre ce que je veux dire c'est que on a
démontré que c'était le moyen de faire
de la flexibilité le plus efficace et le
moins cher après il peut y avoir des
choix politiques à ce que la France
finance des moyens de flexibilité
supplémentaire pour moins dépendre à
quelques heures par an de d'éventuelles
importation mais ça c'est un choix
politique et il faut entendre que ça
aura un coup final çaa un coup sur la
facture du voilà le moyen de flexibilité
le moins cher pour la collectivité
française et en Europe c'est les
interconnexions pi
cuipers merci Madame la la présidente
monsieur le Président tout à l'heure
vous avez dit avec une certaine force
pas de prédiction mais des prévisions
alors j'ai regardé un petit
peu ce que voulait dire l'un et l'autre
et la prévision est un synonyme de la
prédiction sachant que la prédire et
prévoir se rapporte bien évidemment à
l'avenir or le rapport que le bilan en
tout cas prévisionnel et j'y viens page
90 et 91 indique que l'électrification
du parc de voiture et de poids lourd ne
conduit pas à augmenter trop fortement
la consommation
d'électricité tout en insistant sur la
nécessité de développer les
infrastructures de recharge et leurs
mode de pilotage il est dit également
que l'électrification des véhicules
nécessite une consommation d'électricité
de 50 tawh soit 10 % de la consommation
énergétique des transports et peut
permettre une réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre à hauteur de 25
million de tonnes alors comment
parvenez-vous à ces conclusions n'y
a-t-il pas des impensées dans ce dans ce
bilan d'une part je pense que la
réduction des émissions dépendra du
niveau de décarbonation du mixte
énergétique elle dépendra donc
essentiellement de la disponibilité du
parc nucléaire vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure d'autre part je pense également
que la réduction des émissions nécessite
de prendre en compte le cycle de vie
complet du puit à la roue or la
production des batteries électriques
requiert nécessairement des métaux
critiques émissifs dont le lithium je
tiens à rappeler que l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie estime que
d'ici 2 0 l'électrification des
transports engendrera au niveau mondial
une multiplication par 40 de la demande
en lithium par 20 de celle du cobalt et
par 3 de celle du cuivre enfin monsieur
le Président ne faudrait-il pas opter
pour une approche globale de
l'électrification du transport au-delà
du seul transport terrestre en effet
dans le cadre du paquet ajustement à
l'objectif 55 il est prévu la
décarbonation par des carburants
synthétiques durables des secteurs
maritimes et aussi aériens or ces
carburants nécessitent pour leur
production de grandes très grandes
quantités d'électricité enfin selon la
directive des direction générale de
l'énergie et du climat ces quantités
sont de 2 à 3 tawh par an et par site
merci alors j'ai laissé dépasser un
petit peu pierre cuipers parce qu'il
faisait aussi partie des rapporteurs sur
une mission d'information sur
l'hydrogène la mécanisation question
pardon on va être on va être rapide
pourquoi j'ai dit prédiction j'ai pas
dit projection et pas prédiction parce
que j'ai dit que nous ne faisions pas de
prédiction puisque il y a eu le débat à
l'Assemblée nationale dans la commission
souveraineté sur ce qu'avait écrit RTE
dans les années 2010 sur ces projections
de consommation il y a eu débat et il y
a il y a des parlementaires qui m'ont
dit mais que n'avez-vous dit en
2010 vous avez projeté des courbes de
consommation qui étaient flat à échéance
à échéance 2020
2025 donc il y a eu cette
polémique deux
choses nous faisons des projections de
consommation en fonction des paramètres
qui sont connus à un moment donné en
2010 on on était pas dans le dans la
neutralité carbone on était dans le
facteur 4 il y avait pas la R220 il y
avait la RT 2012 qui faisait la grande
place au gaz
fossile les paramètres macroéconomiques
n'étaient pas ceux d'aujourd'hui donc
nous on projette toujours la
consommation de la France en fonction
des politiques publiques qui sont en
œuvre au moment où on le fait et à
l'époque c'était des politiques
publiques de maîtrise de la demande en
matière
d'électricité et nous tirons ces courbes
aussi en fonction de ce qu'on voit des
évolutions macro-économique euh et puis
ce que je veux dire aussi c'est que même
si on nous a fait le reproche d'avoir
fait des courbes de projection qui
étaient flat ou baissière en 2010 bah en
fait nous constatons aujourd'hui 10 ans
plus tard que la courbe de consommation
d'électricité est plate ou baissière
voilà ce que je veux dire c'est que nous
avons un raisonnement hypothético
déductif c'est un peu dur à dire ça veut
dire quoi si la France veut être au
rendez-vous qu'elle a promis alors il
faut qu'elle passe par ce chemin nous
nous ne disons que ça si la France et sa
représentation nationale décide de
changer d'ambition
donacte nous prenons les ambitions du
pays et nous les transposons dans le
monde de l'énergie et de l'électricité
nous ne faisons que ça c'est déjà
beaucoup mais nous ne faisons que ça
donc c'est pour ça que je dis que nous
faisons pas de prédiction et nul n'est
capable de prédire quelle sera la
vitesse d'électrification des usages le
point central monsieur le sénateur c'est
l'électrification des usages sortir des
fossiles c'est sortir de la consommation
fossile donc c'est bien faire en sorte
que les ménages et les entreprises
basculent vers les bioénergies basculent
vers les réseaux de chaleur et basculent
vers l'électricité c'est ça le point
central après nous répond à la question
bah du coup comment est-ce qu'il faut
produire toute cette
électricité et pour répondre monsieur le
sénateur à à vos points sur le transport
pourquoi on dit
que la la l'électrification de de la
mobilité sur le segment des voitures
légères c'est un facteur d'augmentation
mais c'est pas le principal 18 millions
de voitures légères c'est de l'ordre de
35 TWh l'hydrogène qu'il faut produire
en revanche dans le scénario a c'est 60
TWh voilà c'est juste pour donner un
ordre de grandeur en fait qui change
dans ces trajectoires par rapport à la
vision qu'on pouvait avoir il y a 2 3
ans c'est pas vraiment ce qui se passe
sur les véhicules légers c'est plutôt le
fait que les nouvelles directives
européennes conduisent à électrifier
davantage les poids lourds les bus et
encore il y a 3 ans il y avait beaucoup
de constructeurs qui nous disaient moi
je sais pas quel sera mon choix de
décarbonation là il y a eu anticipation
il y a eu des choix industriels pour
l'électrification et ça c'est plutôt la
nouveauté en revanche le de 35 TWh on en
est c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
quelque chose qui a été quasiment pas
débattu dans notre concertation c'est
pas le le débat il a eu lieu sur les
carburants pour l'aviation que vous avez
mentionné et qui pour le coup en 2035
commence à compter et si jamais on se
situe sans modification du transport
aérien et que on passe dans des
carburant durable pour l'aviation qui
sont produits sur le territoire national
à horizon 2050 là ça a un impact très
haut sur les courbes de consommation he
c'est pas les 35 TWh des véhicules
légers euh je je vais dans votre sens
absolument nous faisons toutes les
analyses d'émission de gaz à effet de
serre en intégrant le cycle de vie
aujourd'hui c'est la méthode de
référence et donc je peux vous garantir
que toutes les analyses sur le CO2 que
nous produisons dans le casadre du bilan
prévisionnel et qui seront qui sont
approfondis dans les chapitres dédiés
sont en analyse de cycle de vie et là
encore je vais dans votre sens sur les
métaux lorsque nous avons sorti les
futurs énergétiqu
2050 ça a été peut-être peu relayé parce
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'autres
résultats mais nous avions un
enseignement dédié sur la question des
métaux et des composants rares nous
avons analysé les consommation induite
par ces transformations pour 18 métaux
le lithium le nickel le cobalt
l'aluminium et
cetera il est indubitable que il y a que
l'électrification génère et notamment
pour la
mobilité un besoin en en matériaux qui
est très important dont je peux retirer
deux petits enseignements le premier
c'est que c'est là où les scénarios de
sobriété montrent le plus leur plusvalue
notamment sur la taille des voitures et
donc notamment sur les besoins en
matériaux de l'importance des filières
de recyclage qui permettent de soulager
les besoins d'extraction pour réaliser
ce type de transformation mais ça n'est
pas un impensé même si je pense qu'on a
tout encore attirer les conséquences de
de ce mouvement là mais nous en sommes
parfaitement conscients de la même façon
que si jamais nous arrivons à produire
les batteries sur le territoire national
elles seront moins carbonées là encore
Xavier péchazi l' dit tout à l'heure on
a lancé des investissements alors même
avant même la planification parce qu'on
est conscient des délais du réseau de
transport on souhaite ardemment que ces
batteries soient produites en France
même si elle ne ne l'est pas on a même
si elles sont produites en Asie on
intègre ce coup carbone dans toutes nos
analyses
CO2 alors Yve bleuevenen je demande
encore à nos collègues mais aussi à nos
invités de faire un effort de concision
si on veut arriver à passer l'ensemble
des
questions merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président du directeur de du
directoire de
RTE dans vos propos vous utilisez
souvent le mot de planification de
prévision
d'anticipation et pourtant dans la vraie
vie sur le terrain c'est pas tout à fait
ce qu'on constate avec des décalage
important sur des projets structurants
et je vais vous parler d'un projet dans
mon département qui est sans doute le
plus structurant en terme de
photovoltaïque entre 40 et 50
hectares photo
réalisa avec une ancienne carrière qui
va être requalifiée sur un champ
photovoltaïque
entre 3 et 5 ans de d'avancement de ce
projet et la réponse de RTE c'est 10 ans
pour renforcer le le réseau on est en
cours de révision du fameux schéma S3R
ENR et malgré ça on n'est pas capable
sur le projet le plus structurant dans
un territoire comme la Bretagne de ne
pas être à l'heure au rendez-vous alors
je m'inquiète surtout qu'en parallèle de
ça on a aussi tout le travail qui est
fait sur l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables il y a vraiment un
décalage entre ce que vous nous avez dit
et ce qu'on constate sur le terrain
merci euh bien pris monsieur le sénateur
je connais pas précisément ce projet
vous me je je me permettrais de revenir
vers vous directement je juste vous dire
que ces caslà c'est la raison pour
laquelle les s30nr ont été réformés ce
que vous devez entendre c'est que la
France elle planifiait le développement
des réseaux avec des schémas de
développement des réseaux
qui sont quand même validés par le
préfet he c'est pas un document que nous
faisons nous dans notre coin
euh certains de ces documents avaient
beaucoup de retard et donc lorsque le
gouvernement a déplafonné la possibilité
pour les agriculteurs d'installer des
panneaux photovoltaïque à plus forte
puissance sur leur toit il y a une
explosion du photovoltaïque qui était en
décalage avec les schémas de
planification des réseaux donc on s'est
retrouvé dans dans une situation dans
laquelle les demandes de raccordement
était supérieur à ce que les
professionnels des ENR avaient eux-mêmes
projeté c'est la raison pour laquelle il
y a eu ces dispositions de modification
de ces schémas de
planification et donc
l'enjeu bien évidemment c'est qu'on soit
tous àure la distribution comme le
transport de ces demandes de
raccordement pour ce cas particulier je
ne le connais pas je viendrai
directement vers vous
alors on va passer à Yannick
jade merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le Président désolé j'ai j'ai
oublié le nom de votre
collègue juste une remarque et deux
petites questions très courtes une
remarque vous avez parlé des décisions
de BELFOR et vous avez parlé de la PPE
du gouvernement dans la loi ça sera la
PPE du Parlement donc on se trompe pas
sur je sais qu'en matière énergétique on
a l'habitude de faire les choses à
l'envers dans ce pays mais par la loi
sauf si le gouvernement décidé d'agir
par décret ce sera la PPE du
Parlement une question une première
question rapide vous avez évoqué le
nouveau la nouvelle situation
internationale et ça cette nouvelle
instabilité comment vous intégrez le
fait que les 2/ers de notre uranium
vient de pays Kazakhstan Niger
oubékistan qui sont maintenant plus ou
moins sous influence rus
comment vous intégrez le remplacement du
gaz russe qui était quand même il
fallait s'en s'en passer évidemment
aujourd'hui mais qui est remplacé par du
GNL dont le marché mondial va être
beaucoup plus instable troisièmement
troisème facteur d'instabilité on a
parlé effectivement de la baisse de
l'hydraulique liée à la rarification de
l'eau mais la rarification de l'eau
c'est aussi la question de du
refroidissement de nos centrales deuxème
question sur les PR comment vous quelles
sont les hypothèses aujourd'hui qui sur
les nouvelles capacités de production
électrique je parle bien des nouvelles
quelles sont vos hypothèses sur les prix
relatifs des pr et des énergies
renouvelables enfin dernière petite
question est-ce que vous connaissez on
parle beaucoup des PR2 est-ce que vous
connaissez l'état d'avancement de la
conception je dis bien de la conception
de le PR2 parfois on parle de 30 à 40 %
sur sa conception est-ce que c'est plus
que c'est moi
merci pardon monsieur le sénateur bien
évidemment la PPE fera l'objet d'un
texte voté et débattu dans cette
assemblée j'évoquer le fait que la PPE
finira par être un acte réglementaire
aussi et que de fait nous aurz nous
aurons besoin de cet acte réglementaire
précis pour pouvoir venir rendre compte
devant vous des investissements
nécessaires sur le réseau de transport
tel était ce que je voulais dire
euh on
intègre on intègre les questions
d'instabilité des matières premières je
vais j'ai pas le temps donc je vais pas
revenir sur les questions
uranium gaz et cetera mais on intègre la
question de l'instabilité des matières
premières à travers les simulations
économiques que nous faisons du
fonctionnement du marché européen de
l'électricité à travers le prix spot qui
permet les échanges entre les pays et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
écrit et vous irez le voir en page euh
dans la page qu'on va me donner tout de
suite mais dans une des pages du rapport
qui est sous vos yeux que nous disons
que dans les années qui viennent compenu
de l'instabilité sur les marchés non
mondioau du gaz et des tensions qui peut
y avoir sur le GNL oui il y a une forte
probabilité pour que la plupart du temps
les prix du gaz tirent les prix de gros
deélectricité à la hausse d'où l'enjeu
de trouver des mécanismes de de
convergence de ces prix tirés par le gaz
et on on prend en compte ces tensions
mondiales à travers ce que ça peut
donner sur les
prix aujourd'hui on est venu nous vous
présenter notre notre projection à 2035
à 2035 par définition n'a pas construit
de PR donc pour le prix unitaire des pr
après
2035 nous avons ont fait plusieurs tests
de coût euh euh des pr en euros de
l'époque c'était 50
51 quelque chose mard mais nous avons
fait des tests de coût de LEPR au coût
de flamandville 3 He euh donc tout ça
figure dans les futurs énergétiques
2050 donc nous avons aussi testé des
mondes dans lesquels le coût de
construction de LEPR atteignait celui de
flamandville pour aller jusqu'au bout
hors coup de de portage
financier Sylvia de
Noë merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président nous avons iussi le double
exploit en quelques années à augmenter
considérablement nos besoins en
électricité et à diminuer dans le même
temps nos moyens de production
électrique et cela se traduit
concrètement sur les territoires à
travers deux exemples que je vais vous
donner l'engouement pour les véhicules
électriques qui amènent nombre de nos
concitoyens à s'équiper en bande de
recharge rapide particulièrement
gourmande en électricité et de même
l'installation massive de panneau phot
panneaux photovoltaïqu qui réinjejecte
dans le réseau électrique des volumes
d'électricité qui peuvent s'avérer
importants selon les secteurs or
s'agissant de ces deux phénomènes les
réseaux électriques des communes sont
souvent insuffisamment calibrés pour
absorber ces variations de charg
importantes et il montre des
défaillances récurrentes les élus sont
nombreux à nous faire remonter ces
défaillances et je souhaiterit connaître
comment RTE appréhende ces
problématiques dans le cadre des
missions qui vous sont àarties je vous
remercie je peux pas répondre sur les
questions des réseaux communaux parce
que ça relève de la distribution et ça
relève de la compétence soit des eld
soit d'énedis et donc je vous invite
pour cela discuter avec avec ma collègue
et amie Marian
not simplement vous dire que vu du point
de vue des réseaux et moi je ne peux
parler que du point de vue du réseau de
transport qui s'arrête à 63000 V donc
vous voyez qu'on qu'on reste dans la
dans la haute
[Musique]
tension tous les réseaux sont des
appareils industriels qui sont
compliqués à
transformer et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai insisté depuis le début de
mon intervention sur le besoin de
visibilité et de planification pour que
nous puissions être à l'heure lorsqu'il
le faut nous prenons les risques
financiers pour faire des
infrastructures par anticipation c'est
ce que nous avons fait pour les zones de
décarbonation d'unquer fausse dont j'ai
parlé mais simplement on peut pas
construire une politique
d'investissement que sur des
anticipations parce que ça pourrait
relever de cout échoué partout et euh
s'il y a une boussole qu'il faut qu'on
garde c'est que l'ensemble de ces cous
fixes finissent dans la facture des
entreprises et des ménages donc
l'importance de se mettre d'accord sur
les territoire sur la manière dont les
usages basculent sur les plans bornes le
plus longtemps possible àavance sur la
manière dont les énergies renouvelables
vont se développer qu'on discute avec
les professionnels et avec les élus des
volumes ça permet de faire une
planification industrielle et ça permet
d'être à l'heure tout le monde conçoit
qu'on on ne puisse pas transformer une
infrastructure sur un claquement de
doigt en quelques mois ne sera-ce que
parce que aussi les uns et les autres
vous avez été peut-être et sûrement des
élus locaux et que vous savez que une
partie du réseau urbain de RTE ça passe
par votre voirie c'est sous votre voirie
et
que bien évidemment ouvrir votre voirie
pour transformer le réseau de transport
d'électricité dans les grandes voilà bah
c'est pas facile à faire du jour
lendemain donc il faut entendre ça plus
on arrivera donc à se projeter ensemble
moins on
rencontrera ce type ce type de
désagrément Serge
meriloup merci madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le Président de
RTE pour vos propos extrêmement
intéressants même s n'avez rien de
liminire en début de de
séance moi je veux simplement évoquer la
capacité de répondre aux besoins de pote
ça a déjà été déjà été évoqué puisquen
matière d'électricité c'est aussi un
enjeu être capable d'équilibrer en
permanence le réseau on l'a dit
l'électricité c'est une énergie qui
n'est pas facilement stockable à part
peut-être les batteries et à part
l'énergie
hydraulique parce que là on a une
énergie qui est facilement pilotable ce
qui m'amène à deux questions la première
question c'est et y y a-t-il chez RTE
des scénaris euh de production
d'électricité hydraulique en fonction du
changement climatique ou considère-t-on
comme vous l'avez dit qu'on va rester
stable donc ça c'est une première
question qui pour moi est essentielle
parce que euh l'hydraulique est
probablement
euh l'énergie renouvelable la plus
importante et ma deuxième question qui a
été brièvement évoquée mais sans rentrer
plus dans le détail c'est euh qu'en
est-il des steps des des stations de
transfert d'énergie par
pompage depuis 30 ans on nous parle des
steps EDF est est très intéressé par ce
type de de de moyen qui permet de de
repomper de réutiliser l'eau plusieurs
fois X fois et on a l'impression que
rien ne bouge sur sur ce pointl voilà et
puis on n pas évoqué du tout la
méthanisation donc je je ne sais pas
est-ce que la méthanisation pour vous
est une des solutions ou est-ce que
c'est marginal et puis je termine en
disant que RTE pour moi c'est le réseau
transport alors je pense qu'il y aura
une autre audition sur l'adaptation du
réseau de transport
d'électricité parce que c'est aussi un
enjeu majeur on peut produire de
l'électricité à tour de bras en produire
mais si on n'est pas en capacité alors
vous l'avez évoqué mais mais moi j'étais
un peu sur ma fin de ne parler de voir
parler du mix
énergétique alors que j'attends de lui
aussi des réponses sur sa capacité à
adapter besoin c'est à vous allez je
laisse Tomas répondre je vous ai dit
plan stratégique réseau 2040 réseau de
transport d'électricité 1er trimestre
2024 ou 1er semestre
2024 bien évidemment on sera très
heureux avec Thomas de venir vous le
présenter ici
et très brièvement toujours oui nous
sommes
nous avons des scénarios qui intègrent
qui modélisent le changement climatique
fait avec Météo France l'Institut Pierre
Simon la place et cetera l'impact du
réchauffement climatique sur
l'hydraulique nous sommes les premiers à
l'avoir faire en Europe c'était dans les
futurs énergétiques 2050 on a une
analyse de ce qui se passe l'été
l'automne et cetera et les steps oui
grande valeur après il faut savoir si
notre pays est prêt à reconstruire des
grands des barrages notamment avec des
grands barrages hydrauliques parce que
la valeur d'une step c'est sa capacité
de stockage et donc la la taille de son
bassin Franck Menonville rapidement
Franck oui rapidement merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le monsieur le
Président du du directoire ma question
est simple quelle place imaginez-vous
pour les SMR et notamment leur leur
déploiement territorial leur
complémentarité avec le tissu industriel
et notamment peut-être l'électrointensif
vous avez évoqué le ce la place
prépondérante dans les différents
scénarios de euh du nucléaire quelle est
la au bout de en complément de ces 14
futurs pr la place des SMR et surtout le
cette complémentarité territoriale et
économique dans le scénario n03 de futur
énergétique 2050 nous avons pris
l'hypothèse après la concertation et
notamment après les après une discussion
avec les opérateurs nucléaires français
de mettre 4 GW comme hypothèse de SMR en
France en 2050 c'est beaucoup bah une un
un réacteur New World ça doit faire 170
MW et ça se construit par paire donc ça
fait il faut faire 4 GW divis par 340 ça
doit faire ça fait une douzaine de
paires
euh donc c'est c'est
ambitieux à la question faut-il le
mettre près des sites
électrointensifs
ça dépend s'il y a du foncier déjà
est-ce que ça rend service ça peut
rendre service au réseau ça peut mais
mais je dois vous dire que tout moyen de
production doit s'arrêter à des moments
donnés il doit s'arrêter pour recharger
son combustible il doit s'arrêter pour
maintenance que je parle d'une centrale
à gaz d'une centrale
nucléaire les éoliennes s'arrête parce
queil y a pas de vent tout moyen de
production s'arrête à un moment donné
donc il faut pas se représenter un
système électrique européen et français
dans lequel on colle les moyens de
production au lieu de consommation parce
queil y a toujours besoin de réseau
lorsqu'une centrale nucléaire s'arrête
en France pendant 6 mois il faut que
l'industriel continue à fonctionner et
donc il faut du réseau qui lui amène
l'électricité qui vient d'ailleurs
donc il y a des cas où ça pourrait
rendre service d'installer ces nouveaux
réacteurs dans des zones de forte de
consommation mais rien ne dispense de
faire du réseau lorsque vous êtes un
industriel qui a besoin de gros volume
d'énergie 24 he sur 24 que votre voisin
producteur soit en maintenance ou pas
vous êtes client telle n'est pas la
question donc il faut du réseau en toute
hypothèse frog monoger rapidementadame
présidente merci monsieur le Président
pour cette présentation je je voudrais
saluer comme d'autres l'ont fait
précédemment la qualité de votre étude
de l'étude initiale et et de
l'actualisation que vous présentez
aujourd'hui euh il y a il y a un sujet
euh que je trouve manquant dans votre
approche euh c'est celui de l'analyse
des risques dans votre étude initiale
vous vous vous dites noir sur blanc que
euh il y a de nombreux Paris
technologiques à faire et que le le
système tel qu'il va se se développer
jusqu'en 2050 et et et au-delà sera sera
composé de technologies que l'on ne
maîtrise pas aujourd'hui qui n'existe
pas
aujourd'hui partir de là on est dans un
on est dans un processus de de de de
développement de la démarche et je pense
qu'il aurait été intéressant que vous
dévolopiez une analyse de risque euh que
que que vous auriez pu d'ailleurs euh
que vous pourriez actualiser à chaque
production des des rapports comme celui
que vous présentez aujourd'hui risque
par rapport au au fait de ne pas être
finalement au rendez-vous euh des des
des de l'échéance de 2050 et des étapes
des étapes intermédiaires ça je trouve
que ça manque dans votre étude ou alors
je suis passé à côté c'est c'est c'est
fort possible aussi sur la question des
flexibilités le Conseil supérieur de
l'énergie va être saisi dans sa séance
du 14 novembre d'un projet de
décret expérimental
relatif à des limitations de puissance
appelé par les consommateurs sur des
aires géographiques évidemment pr
prédéfinies ça ça laisse entendre que le
le le le pays et le gouvernement se
préparent à des moments difficiles en
terme de de de de de réponse au au aux
besoins d'appel d'appel d'énergie donc
je voudrais savoir euh voilà quelle est
votre position par rapport à ça c'est un
c'est un moyen de flexibilité que vous
n'évoquez pas est-ce que pour vous c'est
quelque chose qui est amené à se
développer et dernier point sur les
coûts et les prix
euh la diminution euh de la production
d'énergie fossile va affecter certaines
grandes entreprises certaines grands
certains grands groupes comme Total en
particulier où sont pris en compte euh
dans la la la l'analyse des coûts euh
les les coûts les investissements euh
échoués c'est-à-dire les
suramortissements qui vont être
nécessaires par rapport à l'arrêt de
production qui ne sont pas amortis
est-ce que est-ce que ça c'est pris en
compte dans vos coûts et et et dernière
alors c'est vraiment la dernière sur les
prix au final au final par rapport à vos
projections que vont payer les Français
que vont payer les différentes
catégories de consommateurs et je pense
que c'est évidemment un point un
point non non non non ça c'est des coûts
c'est pas des
prix c'est des prix je parle de prix je
parle pas de coût je parle de prix
voilà j'en aur d'autres mais j'
faire alors
euh je vais essayer d'aller le plus vite
possible le projet décret qui est
examiné auxè de limitation de la
puissance appelé sur les compteurs Linky
oui oui oui je vais être clair
euh en France c'est les c'est les marché
qui naturellement grâce à des
dispositifs que nous avons contribué à
créer qui en
fait garantissent l'équip brofre deain
après c'est RTE qui prend la main pour
régler les curseurs
lorsqu'on vit la situation de l'hiver
dernier qu' qu'il y a des risques que la
consommation soit supérieure à la
production il y a ce qu'on appelle des
moyens qui sont hors marché qui sont à
notre main pour régler ces problèmes de
sécurité d'approvisionnement c'est quand
on est dans le monde
d'cat d'coat Orange voire d'coat rouge
le monde décoat Orange c'est le monde où
on active certains moyens de sauvegarde
que vous ne ressentez pas
l'interruptibilité des industriels la
baisse de la
tension et puis le moyen ultime le
risque qui est symbolisé par
l'écoatrouche c'est le risque de coupure
tournante organisé par H entier de
consommation c'est une c'est une
procédure que nous n'avons jamais mise
en œuvre pour des questions d'équilibre
offre dememande nationale qui date d'un
arrêté de
1990 l'éventualité de cette situation
l'hiver dernier a mis enum
un certain nombre de de problèmes que ça
pourrait
générer mais il y a plus d'antennes de
téléphonie mobile aujourd'hui comme
1990 et donc le gouvernement avec les
opérateurs et est entré dans une phase
de modernisation de ces outils de
sauvegarde ultime c'est pas un moyen de
flexibilité c'est un moyen
supplémentaire postmarché pour ne jamais
arriver à ce que vous vous retrouviez
privé d'électricité pendant 2h le
principe est
simple baisser la puissance sur votre
compteur pour que vous ayez
toujours de la
lumière Internet et ca donc c'est un
moyen de sauvegarde supplémentaire et je
crois qu'on en voudrait aux opérateurs
de ne pas essayer de moderniser au fil
du temps nos moyens de sauvegarde
j'insiste les moyens de sauvegarde sont
faits pour ne jamais être utilisé mais
je ne souhaite pas non plus dans
quelques années me retrouver devant
votre commission et que vous me disiez
que n'avez-vous fait pour ne pas
moderniser ces moyens de sauvegarde
parce que nous sommes responsables de
cette SC d'appro donc ce projet de
décret c'est juste un moyen de
sauvegarde supplémentaire beaucoup moins
impactant pour les Français qui nous
permettent de moderniser notre panoplie
pour sauvegarder le système électrique
nous sommes là pour que nous n'entrions
pas dans ce monde là c'est de la
sobriété contrainte quand
même c'est voocation à ne jamais être
utilisé oui oui bien sûr c'est mieux que
des coupures
sèches euh rapidement donc sur l'analyse
des risques c'était centrale en fait
dans l'analyse qu'on a publié en 2021
puisqu'on avait essayé de on avait
essayé de montrer dans les scénarios en
fonction des choix sur les renouvelables
ou les choix sur le nucléaire quel était
quel était le niveau de risque par
contre je pense que ce qui reste
difficile c'est de les mettre tous sur
le même plan parce qu'on a des risques
technologiques on a des risques de
déploiement on a des risques sociétaux
et on a des risques sur la disponibilité
des ressources donc je pense que ce
qu'on peut faire c'est concaténer ces
risques et peut-être les les présenter
de manière dans dans un même endroit en
revanche dire qu'il y aura une forme de
je j'essaie de résister à l'idée qu'il y
a une formule mathématique qui permet
d'arbitrer entre les différents risques
de fait ce sont à la fin des grands
choix politiques des grands choix de
société et qui peuvent nous rendre plus
ou moins résilient à certains risques
maisit excusez-moi c pas ma question ma
question c'est le c'est le risque par
rapport au processus de déploiement de
tout ça donc sur le déploiement sur les
sur les nouvelles technologies je peux
quand même dire une chose en réalité le
fait de faire des flexibilités c'est pas
tellement
nouveau l'asservicement des ballons
d'eau chaude faire du he pleine he
creuse c'est les années 80 90 on a
besoin de faire sur le sur la voiture
électrique des choses que la France a
été en situation de faire il y a 80 ans
avec des systèmes simples voilà donc je
le risque sur le dépoisement des
flexibilités me semble plutôt modéré par
rapport à d'autres dans l'analyse et par
rapport à l'analyse économique oui il y
a il y a des il y a des coûts échoués je
peux pas dire quel est le prix précis
vont payer telle ou telle catégorie
d'utilisateur parce que ça dépend de
tellement de choses euh on peut donner
des régimes on peut expliquer ce que
nous avons fait que dans un système où
les prix du gaz sont élevés le prix du
marché de gros européen a tendance à
être élevé c'est assez mécanique et on
est capable de dire que les centrales à
gaz sont assez fréquemment marginales
pas d'en déduire précisément le prix de
l'électricité sur les marchés en
revanche il y a des cûpts échoués dans
les actifs fossiles c'est certain et
c'est pour ça que la recommandations des
scientifiques c'est pas construire de
nouveaux actifs fossiles aujourd'hui euh
vu le rythme de la transition qu'on
cherche à faire Daniel salmon rapidement
on va essayer de terminer d'ici une
dizaine douzaine de minutes merci madame
la Présidente merci Monsieur pour votre
présentation o effectivement de
nombreuses questions ont déjà été posées
en particulier sur le réseau vous
reviendrez vers nous mais moi je je suis
inquiet de l'acceptabilité des champs de
panneaux photovoltaïques et on sait que
il faut mieux aller vers des plus petits
parcs qui sont beaucoup mieux acceptés
que des très grands parcs mais dans un
souci d'économie d'échelle on sait bien
que on va plutôt aller vers des des
dizaines centaines voir milliers
d'hectares donc comment faire pour que
on puisse raccorder des petits parcs
avec un avec un coût qui soit qui ne
soit pas prohibitif pour que le revenu
issu de ces parcs photovoltaïque soit un
vrai une vraie diversification du revenu
agricole mais ne remplace pas le revenu
agricole voilà ça c'est une question euh
concernant d'autres énergies qu'on n pas
abordé mais qui sont un peu des niches
mais qui qui me sembleent intéressantes
quand même les hydroliennes on a une
hydrolne en Bretagne il y a toujours pas
dans la PPE il y a pas de tarif de
rachat pour les HYD l'énergie issue des
hydroliennes c'est une énergie
prédictible prévisible et je ne
comprends pas qu'on ne la développe pas
plus
aujourd'hui et puis sinon il y a
l'énergie osmotique si vous pouvez n
dire quelques mot sur cette nouvelle
énergie merci sur le photovoltaïque dans
le scénario de référence on fait on a
mélangé de manière assez équilibré le
photovoltaïque sur toiture donc donc
facile à poser et le photovoltaïque
massif avec des
champs après c'est un choix national
simplement plus le plus les
installations photovoltaïques sont
petites plus c'est cher pour la
collectivité donc donc ça c'est un
arbitrage de la collectivité nationale
c'est donc surtout pas de la part d'un
opérateur donc je je je pose ça au
milieu de votre assemblée puisque c'est
là que le débat doit doit se dérouler
finalement à combien est-ce qu'on
valorise l'acceptabilité
de ces
[Musique]
champs-l il est évident qu'on ne pourra
pas faire que du
photovoltaïque par des grandes fermes au
sol
euh mais il faut savoir que faire
uniquement du photovoltaïque sur toiture
c'est beaucoup plus cher et donc il faut
que ce soit un arbitrage équilibré entre
la répercussion sur la facture finale
des ménages et des entreprises et ce
niveau d'acceptabilité qui ne se pose
pas que pour le photovoltaïque qui se
pose pour l'éolien vous le savez qui se
posera aussi pour des nouvelles tranches
nucléaires et j'insiste parce que je
suis aussi un gestion d'infrastructure
qui se posera pour des nouvelles lignes
électrique et je veux vous je veux vous
entendiez que cette électrification elle
passera par la construction de nouvelles
Lig de nouvelles lignes électriques sur
le territoire national y compris des
grandes lignes 400000 V nouvelles et ça
c'est nouveau ça fait de nombreuses
décennies que la France n'avait pas
développé des nouvelles lignes très
hautes tension
sur son territoire
national Catherine Loisier merci
beaucoup monsieur le
Président moi j'ai deux points rapides
d'abord je voulais revenir sur les
enjeux de la modulation vous avez
largement explicité et qui sont
absolument essentiel mais sur la la
compatibilité en fait de ce principe
avec l'optimisation du redéploiement du
du
nucléaire puisque cela veut dire que
finalement nous construisons des
centrales nucléaires qui ne vont pas
fonctionner à pleine puissance du fait
fait de la priorité d'injection des ENR
électriques donc est-ce que vous avez
est-ce que vous êtes livré à une
projection si la France revenait sur ce
principe de de priorité d'injection aux
ENR sachant par exemple que le
Royaume-Uni n'a pas choisi hein de de
mettre en place un un
pilotage de de la puissance de ces
centrales nucléaires et puis l'autre
question pardon l'autre question c'est
sur le dispositif efface efface acte
avec les collec activité avec un certain
nombre de grandes collectivités qui ont
qui est mis en place je vouis savoir si
ce dispositif avait vocation
éventuellement à à s'élargir à d'autres
collectivités merci
oui madame la sénatrice alors en fait il
y a pas de priorité d'injection pour les
énergies renouvelables en France c'est
un dispositif qui a été utilisé par
l'Allemagne il y a 10 ans nous nous ne
l'avons jamais utilisé les énergies
renouvelablebl quand elles sont
produites sont très compétitives donc en
fait dans l'équipe du système européenne
elles ne sont que très rarement écrité
mais des fois le module aussi mais il y
a pas de il y a pas de priorité
technique c'est c'est ça c'est un point
important il y en a
pas le parc nucléaire modulait il
modulait déjà il y a 20 ans il modulait
il y a 10 ans l'idée c'est qu'il ne
module pas plus en volume dans les
analyses prévisionnelles en revanche il
va probablement devoir moduler à
différents moments et sa faculté de
modulation aura plus de valeur pour la
collectivité dit autrement effectivement
quand il y aura des afflus de production
solaire et renouvelabl ça vaudra quand
même beaucoup moins le coup de produire
du nucléaire et ce qui était des fois
économisé puisque les centrales
nucléaires elles sont conçu exploité en
France depuis les années 80 pour moduler
il faudra que
elle déplace place plus de production là
où ça a le plus de valeur mais en volume
ça devrait être au moins à moyen terme
dans les mêmes ordres de grandeur
qu'aujourd'hui en revanche des fois il y
aura plus de profondeur de la modulation
qui sera nécessaire c'est-à-dire plus de
réacteurs qui moduleront en même temps
et effasact je suis désolé je ne
jeis niche d'énergie là de Daniel sal je
peux pas vous répondre sur eff Act non
plus voilà mais on en parle après si
vous voulez
ouais je j'insiste sur ce qu'a dit
Thomas il y a pas de priorité technique
d'injection des énergies renouvelables
sur le
réseau c'est il y a pas de priorité
technique du tout
après lorsqu'une énergie renouvelable
produit de l'électricité à coût marginal
nul c'est normal qu'elle s'impose sur le
marché alors que même si les coûts donc
d'exoitation du nucléaire sont très
faibles ils sont pas
nuls et quand vous regardez la
production maintenant quand les prix
sont négatifs vous voyez que l'énergie
éolienne et l'énergie solaire diminue
aussi Philippe crobalet
oui la Loire Atlantique est une terre
j'allais dire une mer également
aujourd'hui assez emblématique sur
l'histoire de de l'énergie dans notre
pays
1930 implantation d'une raffinerie puis
de début des années 60 fin des années 60
une centrale au charbon on parler c'est
d'actualité dans les années 70 c'est un
projet de centrale nucléaire rejeté par
les populations en masse validé ensuite
par un gouvernement et puis évidemment
très récemment le premier parc éolien
offshore en France et la première
éolienne flottante testée sur les eaux
j'allais pas dire les eaux territoriales
de Loire Atlantique et puis le projet
d'écocombust initié par les salariés
d'une entreprise et et l'industriel a
mis un peu de temps à réagir même si
aujourd'hui ça semble validé mais
surtout ce parc éolien offshore dont on
sait que à peine un an après sa mise en
route il pourrait théoriquement produire
avec les la filière industrielle qu'on a
en plus développer sur notre territoire
produire au moins deux fois plus voire
trois fois plus donc je voulais vous
poser la question de savoir dans dans
les projets de centrale je parle de
centrale éolienne d'ailleurs plus que de
parc éolien les projets de grandes
centrale éolienne offshore en France 2è
puissance mondiale en eau maritime
quelle est la véritable ambition
avez-vous vous quelle leçon retenez-vous
de l'implantation de ce premier de cette
première centrale et est-ce que le
développement de de ces centrales
éoliennes offshore est limité quels sont
les freins principaux y compris les
frein financiers c'est-à-dire de ceux
des investissements qui vont plutôt vers
le nucléaire que plutôt vers le l'éolien
merci le potentiel français est très
grand il est presque dès lors qu'on fait
de l'éolien
flottant cet éolien flottant permet de
mettre les parcs loin des
côtes mais aujourd'hui c'est une
technologie substantiellement plus chère
que de faire de l'éolien offshore
posé le bilan qu'on fait du premier parc
de saint-azer il est très bon il
fonctionne le raccordement fonctionne la
France sait métriser ses technologies ce
sera du même type dans les jets qui
seront mis en service à saint-briux
fécul
coursant courul fécan
Noirmoutier Le
Tréport les générations suivantes sert
des générations qui sont plus lointaines
des côtes qui seront plus coûteuses en
raccordement jusqu'à
après le choix national de des volumes à
termees des lien posé ou flottant c'est
le choix c'est un choix structurellement
souverain donc c'est pas à nous de le
faire c'est à
VOUS Eveline Renaud garabédian merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président RTE
International est une société de conseil
fournissant des services à des
gestionnaires du réseau de transport
électrique ainsi que à des producteurs
d'énergie renouvelable dans le monde
entier et notamment en Afrique première
petite question pezvous m'indiquer quels
sont les pays d'Afrique qui sont
concernés par vos installations je suis
sénateur des Français établis hors de
France et à ce titre particulièrement
intéressé par la situation des Français
vivant à l'étranger pouvez-vous
m'indiquer si dans ces activités à
l'étranger Vous employez du personnel
français merci de vos réponses
oui RT internationale est une société
une de nos filiales qui valorise les
compétences de RTE groupe et
historiquement du monopole RTE notamment
en matière d'ingénierie donc il y a pas
de de politique euh pays par pays nous
candidatons à des appels d'offrees qui
sont ici ou là euh soit passés par des
gouvernements soit passés par des
opérateurs de réseau et la plupart du
temps nous intervenons à travers nos
ingénieurs en tant que structure de
conseil
euh je vais m'arrêter là le mieux c'est
que nous puissions avoir un contact
direct et qu'on vous informe des pays
euh notamment d'Afrique sur lesquels
nous avons soit déjà des clients soit
nous avons des
prospects c'est une filiale qui est
composée de plusieurs dizaines de
salariés et qui
fait qui fait entre 10 et 20 millions
d'euros de chiffres d'affair donc c'est
c'est c'est une activité d'ingénierie
accessoire à ce que nous faisons par
ailleurs et qui est dédié uniquement à
l'export du savoir-faire français c'est
pour ça que nous le faisons Michel bonus
et ensuite on terminera avec Bernard bu
merci madame la Présidente ça va être
très court est-ce que vous avez envisagé
surtout étudier les conséquen et
l'impact sur sur le monde de
l'entreprise des commerces des artisans
de de la politique
tarifaire non parce que vous parlez de
prix et et nous nous sommes nous nous
n'avons pas à nous à nous proposer à
nous à nous à nous prononcer sur les
prix ça relève d'institutions qui ne
sont pas RTE d'ailleurs nous sommes une
entreprise nous sommes pas une
institution à proprement
parler les impact sur les entreprises
c'est la politique de tarification c'est
de la
compétence bah des assemblées et du
gouvernement d'une part et de l'autre de
la CRÉ donc aujourd'hui je peux pas vous
je peux pas répondre à votre à votre
question autrement que ce qu'on a déjà
fait c'est-à-dire de dire que la France
a un mix de production d'électricité
suffisamment compétitif pour qu'elle ait
une consommation euh euh pour qu'elle
ait une facture d'énergie acceptable à
la fois pour les entreprises et pour les
ménages du fait de son parc nucléaire
déjà et du fait des énergies
renouvelables qu'elle met en œuvre et là
euh on revient sur la question de la de
la convergence progressive des prix vers
les coûts alors dernière question
Bernard buis merci euh madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Président
pour la clarté de vos propos moi j'aurai
une question très rapide dans quelle
mesure les conséquences du dérèglement
climatique provoquent-elles des dégâts
sur les infrastructures du réseau RTE
avez-vous une idée du chiffre du du
montant du coût
Merci c'est un sujet que nous étudions à
fond depuis plusieurs années ça a déjà
eu des impacts notamment sur un certain
nombre de composants qui avec la chaleur
ou des grands gradientss de température
disfonctionnit c'est un sujet qui sera
traité dans notre plan stratégique
réseau 2040 et si vous nous faites
l'honneur de nous réinviter invité c'est
à cette occasion qu'on pourra rentrer
dans le détail de l'adaptation du réseau
de transport d'électricité aux
problématiques de réchauffement c'est
après 2035 c'est bien après mais bien
évidemment c'est quelque chose qu'on
prend en compte dans le dimensionnement
du renouvellement de nos installations
oui en tout cas merci beaucoup monsieur
le Président du Directoire Monsieur le
Directeur de l'exécutif pour ses
réponses très précises très détaillé
vous avez vu qu'il y avait une certaine
appétence de la part de l'ensemble de
nos commissaires et on a bien pris acte
que vous nous donniez rendez-vous
peut-être dans le courant de l'année
2024 pour refaire un point avec votre
entreprise merci en tout cas et on vous
souhaite une bonne journée parce que
vous nous avez consacré énormément de
temps je vous remercie de votre accueil
de vos questions et vous dire que nous
sommes à la disposition de la
représentation nationale et donc de
chaque sénatrice et de sénateur si vous
aviez des points particuliers dont vous
souhaitiez discuter avec nous nous
sommes avec quelques collaborateurs et
s'il y a des points part particulier
comme ça a été le cas donc en Bretagne
on est à votre entière disposition pour
poursuivre cette discussion comme et
comme c'est le cas aussi pour les Alpes
Maritimes et leev avec ce qu'on a subi
sur la coupure d'électricité important
madame la Présidente
pardon